Boom and we're alive.
Russell,
why is it then when people start getting like super spiritual,
they start dressing like you.
You dress like a guru.
We sat key lay a memo so it's now time has stopped wearing socks,
stopped shaving and make eye contact for a bit too long.
Oh it uncomfortable.
Stary how long are you going to go with the beard?
I mean that's,
that's like you're,
you're full on like you're a Yogi now.
I mean it's gone be on Jesus and Moses and lesser profits or test or a navy
seal.
You are in that range to like you could be some wild man.
That's,
that's a mistake that wouldn't like if there was an assault course in front of
us that have the potential for me being a navy seal would start to break down.
I once went on a an assault course.
We have some US marines in that place near San Diego.
I can't remember the name of that base and climbing up that rope using your leg
muscles.
It was not good value and enjoy it.
I like the camaraderie and I'd really like I as I've written about and talked
about quite a lot when I'm around very in very male environment,
I kind of really like it.
I really get off on it,
but I have to watch myself not getting too excitable.
It's even in this environment.
As a matter of fact,
I have to keep myself a little bit chilled out.
Why?
What do you mean?
What does it do to you?
Well,
I guess what it is is my early life,
I grew up mostly around my mum and dad have brothers and sisters and stuff like
that,
so my male role modeling occurred later in life and I think it probably relates
to the spiritual thing.
I think it meant that I was,
I'm very open to sort of spiritual experience,
meditative experience,
so I didn't have a lot of grounding physical experiences or bodily experience.
He's really till adolescents until sex and sexuality as a first time I really
sort of got into the body,
didn't do sport as a kid,
didn't have like main guy,
right.
This is what we do,
this is how we shave.
This is how you treat people.
This,
you know,
I didn't really get that kind of education.
So now steel,
if I'm around like soldiers,
UFC fight as I go,
you know,
I'd be BJJ primarily as a result of these conference where there's not Colum
confrontation counselors conversations.
That's a much nicer term.
So like there's a bit of me that's the guy gave excited about the analysis of
it.
It's not homoerotic because that doesn't happen to be the way that I roll out.
Just enjoy a little too much.
There's something about it.
Yeah.
And it may well what's bad about it?
What's,
what's bad about getting fired up?
Nothing for me.
I except like,
you know,
look my,
as you know,
my model for life is as sort of a 12 step model about watching my impulses.
My impulses of got me in a lot of trouble.
My impulse is to take drugs.
My impulse is to sleep around my,
like my impulse is to even eat food.
I've got a sort of a tendency to get obsessive.
But you know,
you would probably argue that if you direct that energy correctly,
it can be kind of positive.
I think it can,
but I agree with you that it can get out of control and I have similar impulses,
I have problems and I've just used disciplined and hard work,
especially working out to try to mitigate it.
Well that's why I pick up from you is that your early encounters with Marsha,
lots of men that you've understood from a young age.
It seems to me physical discipline and I think that's a very important thing.
And I'm only learning that like now because I've had a like,
you know,
drugs then fame there and chaos and I've only just a merge from like the sort of
the fog of that madness.
I love how you have emerged though,
cause it's very unique.
You've,
you,
you've uniquely emerged authentically.
Like you've,
this is who you really are.
Like you're not putting on an act you found yourself,
which is like what everybody wants to do.
They want to find themselves.
I mean it never feels like a completed task,
right?
It.
Everyone's a work in progress forever.
That's why,
but you are,
you like you are very comfortably you and you've found what makes you you.
That's a lovely compliment to get from you,
Joe.
I appreciate that because what I think about is like you're a very different
type of person.
To me it things that in this world,
in these political times,
you and I would be supposed to,
I would say a take adversarial stance is on,
I'm Vegan now you love hunting,
but my personal philosophy is my morality and my spirituality is for me.
It's not something I go around,
inflict it on other people and telling them how they should behave.
I I know enough now to know people are different people at different experiences
and I don't let those things get in the way of how I evaluate other people or we
should all be more like that.
I really,
I really believe that.
I mean there's so many people that or disagree with that I have fun
conversations with.
I don't think there's anything wrong with that.
And then I don't think that impulse to to have antagonistic engagements with
people that you disagree with is correct.
How else are we going to consolidate?
Like it's just like I'm only going to deal with people that see the world
roughly how I do.
How are we going to form new tribes,
new alliances,
new relationships,
new system at a time when evidentaly it feels to me at least Joe,
like things are breaking down.
There's a lot of bitterness,
a Serby and confrontation and people don't want to talk to you.
But I mean,
I don't know how real that is of actual people.
I'm talking,
I suppose about how the media landscape seems to present information.
I don't know if that's true when you're,
you know,
when I'm around people I don't sense,
oh wow,
these guys are really tied up in Brexit or Trump or whatever.
It doesn't seem that relevant toward an airy people.
It seems to me that people are still operating on a,
in a personal,
how are you today?
You look at,
you know,
people that are willing to get on like that.
I mean,
how,
how are we supposed to take these ideas on board?
It's sort of almost too vast for us.
Geopolitical ideas that we were asked to identify with.
Right.
And then your everyday life hardly ever affects you or affects you very little
in comparison to things that you ignore because you're concentrating on Brexit
or are you concentrating on Trump or you're concentrating on whatever it is?
Yeah.
That wall build that wall,
whatever it is.
Yeah.
I start to wonder who is it that's involved in this stuff?
I started at what it's,
where I'm at now is all we even capable of belonging to groups,
units,
tribes of free hundred million people or 60 million people with so many diverse
ideas.
Is this a time to look at federalism differently to start breaking down?
Well,
you know the,
I exist within this tribe of people,
but I collaborate with all these other people.
I don't know how municipal action gets done and now you run an army and build
roads if people are starting to operate in smaller units.
But I am thinking that we need to have a real sense of community and connection
and we've got to let go of looking for ways to object to and judge other people
is some sort of primary fault way of forming our own identity.
No,
I completely agree and I think we're probably moving towards some sort of
understanding that a lot of these boundaries and these clans of,
you know,
states and countries,
they were all established without our consent before we're born and we're,
we're just,
we're a part of a system that we just were,
we didn't agree to it.
We just all of a sudden found ourselves in it and we're trying to make it fit
us.
Yeah,
that's right.
And there's aspects of it that are appealing,
you know,
like sort of [inaudible] a world cop I've really sure English and know like I
feel a genuine sense of connection and investment.
But if I'm being asked to live according to rules that don't affect me,
that affect except for you know,
that for affect me financially and don't speak to I am as an individual.
Then I'm like,
well what is this?
This is it for my benefit.
Yeah.
When the inclination to form teams and to root for your team and a root against
other teams,
it's a,
it's so deep seated in us.
It's a,
and it can cause so many unnecessary conflicts for no reason.
It's just,
it's,
it's so,
it's so escapable too.
It's,
it's some,
so if you can objectively analyze the way human beings behave and interact with
each other and go,
well why do we do this?
Let's just stop doing that.
Which is to,
if we disagree on things,
how much are these disagreements actually affecting me on a daily basis.
Dot.
That much.
Can we just communicate?
Can someone say what they think?
And I say what I think and we just decide like what makes sense and what doesn't
make sense based on our own interpretations.
Cause isn't that possible?
It seems like it's,
that's the direction we'd go ahead.
And I did a,
as I know you have done a podcast with Candice Olin's who like on the subject
of,
you know,
individual like when she says stuff like that people should get over slavery or
it's as if it didn't happen.
I don't agree with that.
I feel like that has a massive social impact.
That is that those statistics are not coming incidents,
the number of people or certain ethnicities in prisons and in poverty or
wherever.
For me,
that's not just the coincidence,
but as I said,
I couldn't agree with more profoundly on according to social criteria,
some very,
very important issues on an interpersonal level of which she was absolutely
delightful,
but like sort of funny and sweet
and she's
very young.
If you really start the things that what's going on only 28 which is amazing.
Right?
Is that correct?
She's so much smarter than I was when I was 28 she sent me a lot more competent
and that was 29 28 or 29 same thing.
So when I was 29 I was a fucking moron.
Okay.
And no one would ever listen to my opinions on anything and on,
on the world stage.
People are listening to her.
I mean she's,
she's testifying in front of Congress.
so I cut her a lot of slack with some of the things that she's made,
like misstep,
stepson that I think sometimes when people say those things like people should
get over slavery.
It's like,
it's almost like you're saying things that you think other people want to hear
more than you're saying things that are really rational.
So whether or not we should get over slavery.
Sure.
Slavery was over more than a hundred years ago,
but the repercussions of slavery,
the echoes of slavery still exists and they exist in all these different
southern states and cities and all these different neighborhoods that had been a
part of systemic racism where they had literally forced black people to live in
certain areas and didn't even allow them to buy homes outside of those areas.
They made laws and those laws are in place in places like Baltimore.
And you know,
I had this Guy Michael Wood on [inaudible] who was a police officer and the city
of Baltimore.
And one of the more profound things that he said was that they found papers that
we're documenting crimes from the 1970s in Baltimore and they were in this same
area,
the same crimes that he was facing in the two thousands when he was a police
officer.
So he was looking at this going,
what in the fuck?
Like this is,
am I just a part of something that's never going to be fixed and never going to
be changed?
And you know,
as he learned more about the city and the city's laws and how these,
these systems were set up to keep people in certain places and how the crime and
the violence and the drugs is all just in this one concentrated area and it's
always been there and no one does anything to change it.
You realize like,
wow,
this is a,
this is a crazy echo of a horrible past.
And that's what it is.
I had a couple of conversations that made me recognize how powerful systems and
institutions are and their ability to maintain themselves.
It regardless of any individual cause it seems like what happened there with the
man you are chatting to is that he's an individual woke up and like,
oh my God,
hold on a second.
In some sort of weird grid and like I spoke to his fellow called Ken Ross who
worked for the British diplomatic service at the time of nine 11 and was privy
to confidential information about how that was handled on a military and
geopolitical level and he said like he's come away from that thinking,
well these institutions function and in a totally corrupt way to pursue their
own objectives.
This ingenuity and dishonesty is just part of the system and it was him that
made me think about antiques ism in a different way.
Saying that people,
the assumption that people,
if they were not tightly governed with big government and huge control would go
around merger in each of them raping each other simply not true.
That's one of the means by which the state continues to justify its existence.
People will behave better the closer they are to self governing community self
governing committee and they sit light.
And I was interested in that because he's talking from,
this is why a sore on the inside,
this is how I saw it was running like your cop friend there and like,
uh,
another person I spoke to that had been inside the system and then woken up
within it,
he was like,
oh,
you have Yanis Varoufakis he was,
when Greece had that mad revolution,
he was like one of the leaves of a party.
Syriza and for a minute it was like the reason I said,
we ain't paying back all those debts.
You screwed us financially.
You've screwed Greece.
So he was there at the EU means telling like the German chancellery,
we're not Paris,
Greece ain't gonna repay those debts.
And he just said that the way that the system reassert itself was magnificent to
watch in a way.
And he said,
none of those individuals have any power except the power that that role gives
them.
If you are the German finance minister,
you've got the power of the German finance minister has,
you can't step outside it and start going,
right,
listen,
why don't we do this and why don't we do that?
The system itself is beyond individual decisions.
You know it's,
it's a self sustaining system.
It won't come up with ideas or support ideas that threaten it and that's why I
continue to keep hearing and I'm sure you're having similar conversations that
if you are really interested in changing the world,
you have to participate in systems that are outside of it.
Set up new ideas.
Don't worry about trying to smash this one down with a hammer.
It will atrophy on its own as it becomes less and less relevant.
I think also change yourself and when you change yourself becomes evident to the
people around you.
And if your change is beneficial and attractive people,
they gravitate towards that idea that you can improve yourself and you can
change your perspective on things.
Well that is the one area of your life where you've got some are for it in
control.
And that's the,
that is what I'm about is like the y can stop myself being like,
uh,
watching pornography.
I can stop myself using drugs if I want to.
Like,
you know,
we have some support and that's what that this book here mentors which are
talking about you in early for paragraph,
you know what I mean?
It's not too,
it's not like a like literary fellatio it's a small knot of your uh,
of your influence and impact.
I talk about how we have latent latent qualities within us that are sometimes
hard to realize on,
on without support.
But if you find a mentor in an area where you're looking to improve,
they can kind of energize,
awaken energies within you that on your own you wouldn't be able to use.
I had a really reasoned experience of it where I was sort of like freaking out
about something I spoke to like a men or of mine.
And like the way that you sort of spoke to me was like sort of aggressive,
like at a sort of an aggressive,
that's not going to happen.
You are not afraid and like it's sort of,
it woke up the part of me that's feels that way,
that has that kind of,
I would say sort of a male certainty are kind of grounded energy.
He was able to sort of like the rectory at me and like in that moment in myself
or bewildered,
I wasn't able to do it,
you know,
a needed to resource it externally in a moment.
So this is how I sort of feel like your individual journey.
I'm interested in how,
because I'm guessing with your background in martial arts and stuff,
men or ships seems pretty much stitched into that you must continually be
looking at someone learning from someone,
trying to equal them or whatever it is.
Yeah.
The good part about that,
as you get good at learning things and you get good at listening,
you know,
uh,
as a martial arts student,
you,
you don't just listen,
you listen very intently.
You bow,
you say,
sir,
you know,
I mean there's a,
there's so much discipline involved in the,
the,
the act of learning and so much reverence and respect for people know more than
you and appreciation.
So,
uh,
that,
that helped me with pretty much everything I ever wanted to learn.
I just would listen very intently and I don't think,
oh,
maybe I could figure it out better.
I will.
I'm very good at listening to people that are good at things.
Fast
chest in Digi first,
get into,
uh,
like,
you know,
I've picked up stuff over the various shows of yours that I've listened to,
but would you say that your inaugural interest in martial arts came from kind of
domestic distress and stuff like that,
but a difficult home life and,
and not a good relationship with your stepdad and my right.
That was there,
but it was,
it was also moved moving more than anything.
You know what I missed up?
Does a nice guy.
Um,
but it was stepped out.
It's always a weird situation.
You know?
No one likes the dynamic of someone having sex with their mother.
I remember similar feelings about my own step.
That one
great guy though.
I don't want to like,
no,
of course I'm in a bad way.
It's just what it was really hard was moving a lot and running into bullies.
That was way harder than anything else.
So there was a time in your life where you felt very uh,
presumably vulnerable and not grounded,
didn't have any friends constantly moving in new neighborhoods,
meeting New People and uh,
you know,
and when you were a young boy,
you're a teenage boy.
Teenage boys are fucking dangerous.
And it was the worst
group of them.
Now I am talking about my country for in 14 years old are across the street.
Yeah.
Eh Lord this well,
young boys are just,
they're always looking to impress each other and they have these,
if you want to find real toxic masculinity,
it exists in teenage boys,
you know,
and it's mostly saturated,
didn't men,
the way it's described is mostly exaggerated in terms of the way the media talks
about it,
but in its purest form and teenage boys,
they get together and they start light and frogs on fire.
And doing shit.
They do things because they want to like one up each other and they feed off of
each other.
Like what one boy would do is so different than what five boys would do,
what five boys would do,
who could be horrific but with one boy would do on his own.
It's very rarely there of what you know.
You have to think about yourself and think about is this right?
And you objectively analyze the way you're behaving.
And I'm like,
um,
yeah,
and people wouldn't be proud of me if I did it this way.
When you're with five other boys and you're all rambunctious and filled with
testosterone and piss and vinegar,
you wind up doing crazy things.
This is I,
you know,
when I hear something like that,
it's difficult not to think that it's,
of course relative relative to us,
the behavior of adolescent mouse is reckless and crazy.
It's not impossible to conceive of an intelligent that would look at the
behavior of adult human beings and think,
oh my God,
all governing these people.
What principals,
so they using right now
goal two.
Like,
what are you trying to accomplish with your life,
with your existence,
with your time?
I think if there's a real concern about Ai,
I think the real concern is AI is going to rationally analyze our behavior and
our reliance on emotions and all these human reward systems that we have built
in the way it's affecting our society and the way it's affecting how we govern
ourselves and how we behave amongst ourselves.
And it's going to think we're unfixable.
It's going to look at it and like,
well,
this is,
they have too much monkey in them.
They have so much monkey instincts and monkey DNA.
But now they live in this rational,
modern world of,
you know,
five g internet on your phone and satellite communication and 24,
seven news cycle.
But yet they have these primate
jeans,
artificial intelligence,
uh,
subjects about,
which I know very little seems to me that it would on some level have to be
derived from a particular aspect of human understanding of rationalism.
So we're represent in one aspect of our nature and prioritizing it.
Logic,
uh,
organization.
But what you refer to as sort of primitive and monkey ish for me envelops and
involves the most beautiful aspects of our nature.
I'm a little romantic about human being still.
I still feel that.
I feel that one of the great problems we've had is that philosophically we have
overvalued materialism rationalism and like kind of knowing a little bit about
philosophy primarily from that bloody podcast that you and I tagged a minute ago
before we was recording.
Who's that going to last for as this?
So like what?
Why understand for that?
It's like Polish the enlightenment.
We've started to prioritize rationalism.
So if you prioritize rationalism and organization,
which obviously has a lot to offer,
the organization of resources is incredibly and hugely important.
You forget that a huge part of the human experience is nothing to do with that.
The other thing we were chatting about before we went live with DMT now know
artificial intelligence is going to understand that there is access to a realm
of consciousness that continually exists that doesn't seem to be bound by
physical laws as we understand them.
And if the physical laws that we abide our parochial and relevant only to this
level of existence,
why are we allowing ideas resourced from there to govern all of our systems.
You know,
even listen to you talk about the empty and you now I encountered these
gestures.
I the adjusters are went through this membrane into another realm and checking
out Mike Tyson when he was on here.
[inaudible]
amazing.
Like,
uh,
like the clear like,
you know,
I only,
I took acid when I was a teenager and even in very unhealthy cannot.
I'm healthy but blight,
unbridled mad teenage boy conditions.
I,
you know,
I want to be there with a guy in a lab coat with a pen going,
well Mr. Brown,
sit down and look at these Rorschach tests instead of which I mean new cross in
a bedsit dropping acid and staring at my own hands.
And recognizing,
oh my God,
I'm not me.
The very idea of me as a construct,
I'm just tuned into a particular aspect.
I AI will build systems that are,
that are predicated on rationalism organization and I on on that basis,
I can see why they would at some point,
yeah,
go all skynet and annihilate us.
But that is,
I believe the problem with our society is that the materialistic aspect of our
nature is not the priority.
It's just one thing we should be doing because we need good roads because many
hospitals,
schools,
food,
et cetera.
But we need to find a way of honoring the sacred.
And I'm fascinated in the experiences you're having in these psychedelic
explorations and how it's influencing the rest of your life.
Like how you're saying like how your,
how does it influence the rest of your decisions,
the way you see the world,
the way you see relationships,
the way you see the vulnerable young man you were prior to building your own.
I say personal religion of Marcia Lars,
excellence in your chosen field of standup comedy.
How do you incorporate that vulnerable kid?
Cause I'm still very aware of the vulnerable person.
I was like,
I'm going on a rant man.
Like when Kevin Hart was on here who I think he's amazing and he was amazing on
this.
I thought fucking hell.
Like what have I got to offer the world?
When Kevin Hart has got this kind of force,
you don't come in the bubble and not.
I was like,
my God,
this guy is so positive.
What a role model more he's got to offer and then I thought,
well,
like any of us,
what I've got to offer is who I am,
just who I am and then vulnerable,
flawed human being.
There's still feels connected to the kid I was when I didn't feel good enough.
I still feel that I can walk in a room and feel that.
I also know that that that's not real because I've had spiritual experiences,
hallucinogenic experiences that make me feel that the relationships we should be
building have to honor that we are both,
we are vulnerable and flawed but also capable of greatness.
There has to be room for all of this.
And I feel that part of what we're doing and part of why we're experiencing such
superficial polarity in politics and culture is cause we're not acknowledging
that underneath this surface activity of left,
right,
left,
right.
And you know,
from Sam Harris,
them little experiments,
you stick garbage in front of a pest.
I'm on their blade,
become Republican pretty quickly.
Or You,
you know,
you scare people,
they become less democratic.
You know,
I think all that stuff is pretty superficial and at depth in that realm of the
gestures and the membrane of Psychedelia,
we have access to oneness and that should be what's influencing the way we set
up our tribes,
our systems and our relationship.
Yeah.
I think when a guy like Kevin Hart shows you what a,
a positive and motivational,
uh,
impact one person can have just with his words and his deeds and the way he
lives his life,
he's so inspirational that you realize,
uh,
that,
that that is possible.
That you can share that energy and that you can have these experiences with
people where they literally do actually they actually uplift you.
Like I was uplifted by his conversation.
I felt like,
wow,
that guy is so positive.
What a great way to look at the life that we're living.
And the more people do that,
the better.
And when someone like that does spread a positive message,
you know,
and obviously he's got,
he's materialistic as well.
He's got a bunch of cars in a big house and he makes a lot of money and he does
a lot of movies.
But what he's spreading is this very motivational,
very positive message and that affects people in a very positive way to and all
that left right shit and all this,
uh,
the,
all the battles that we have politically and ideologically back and forth and
all the negative venom that people spray at each other at the end of the day,
that this is not benefiting anyone unless you're fighting some,
uh,
major and that the world needs to conquer in most of that.
Most of it's not that.
Most of it is like finding demons out of innocuous things.
You know?
And I think when you talk about what,
what you have to offer,
well you have to offer is that you are you,
that you have this unique perspective,
you,
you can affect the way people view their own journey in life because you've been
so introspective and so aware of your own pros and cons in terms of your past
behavior,
your current behavior and who you are now and who you used to be.
All that stuff is fuel for people because they can relate.
They hear it.
I mean maybe they not relate it to being a movie star and being this famous guy
and the strip,
but they can relate to the humanity of your struggle.
They put themselves in your position like what must that have been like?
And look at this guy who has made these conscious decisions to not be like that
anymore.
And He dresses like a homeless person with a crazy beard.
That's the real take home information.
Dress like you live out of doors.
Yeah.
Just like you're a homeless guy in Oregon
specifically there people will respect that.
Yeah,
it's like a dark colors,
you know,
it rains a lot and I get it.
I get the reference and I understand American culture.
Joe Rogan.
Yeah.
So um,
hey can I do some Como like tell me what it's called.
What is it?
This book is called mentors and I,
I read like I read bits of it again cause I knew I was coming here and I think
he's actually pretty good.
Like I wrote quite a lot about Brazilian Jujitsu.
Really Love It,
Huh?
Yeah I do.
My writing is not from a,
you'll understand not from a technical perspective.
I'm not saying this is what I've got to say on open guard to transition.
I'm talking about how the psychological impact that it's had on me and also in
there about like the protocols of going to a group which as a beginner are very
relevant.
Like you touched on how ritualized it is.
I got a hunch that the more we emulate and connect to original ways of human
behavior,
whether that's diet tree or hierarchies or organization of groups,
I feel that we will feel a sense of greater connection.
Now the thing I got from Gannon Bjj classes,
genesis,
where I'll go back in England is like that all the white belts get changed at
one end of the room,
the purple belts and above get changed at the upper end of the room,
which coincidentally or not is where the control for the timer is and the
control for the music is and where the kit is.
That's all up that room to enter the room.
So all the control is that end,
but it begins with sort of dancing around in a circle,
doing all of those various exercises.
Now lift your knees,
now do the shrimp in and that kind of stuff.
It's the lower belt.
Shouldn't invite a higher belt to spa or role,
you know,
it's that and like the,
as you say,
the amount of respect,
the bowing,
the handshaking at the end of it,
it's so soft.
It provides such a safe environment in which to deal with the primal.
I can see why it's valuable and it's the like,
you know,
I should been taught that shit when I was 1413 like Amanda terribly so that I
didn't come across it.
Like,
you know,
you're not going to be setting fire to feel Jen allotments and put in frogs on
fireworks if you've got a way of dealing with that primal energy when,
when it's coming.
So I don't understand that.
Think that you should suppress it somehow.
We should just ignore it or suppress it.
They don't understand that when men it really ever a biological male,
it really needs to be tackled head on.
I mean,
you really,
you really need to embrace what it is to be a physical mail and it frees you in
a lot of ways.
Do you think this might be a comparable moment too in the 1960s when there was a
sort of a sense of sexual repression versus sexual free love?
You know,
the images of Woodstock and flowers in their hair and smoking joints and having
sort of sex outdoors in mud or possibly wheat that,
that,
that this time of like a kind of an anger about maleness and maleness may not,
as you said,
it may be a biological male bay,
it could be the energy of,
I don't know,
assertion or wherever these like,
you know,
as in grammar in male and female relate to certain words as in French grammar
where,
I don't know,
Kat is female and doggies mount,
I don't know the system,
I don't speak French,
but I'm saying that these,
we have labeled these entities and it does seem that a,
that there is a particular,
and what I want to say,
condemnation of male energy.
Do you think you can,
I'm from a misunderstanding.
Yeah.
And also
I think it comes from a big generalization to yeah,
it's easy to do,
right?
And,
and if you're a woman has had negative experiences with men,
maybe you've dated men that had been physically abusive or maybe known men that
had been physically abusive and you,
you were around that and you just,
uh,
it's,
it's very convenient and very easy to just generalize and decided that all men
are negative.
Masculine energy is negative and especially white males.
And if you say that you'll get props online,
people go,
yes,
girl,
clap,
clap.
People get excited.
But those are also people that are short sided.
Like you want to make as many people,
your allies.
You can,
you want to make as many people,
your friend as you can.
And you have to understand that there's some people that are just wired
different than you.
There's some,
there's some girly girls and there's some really feminine men.
And then there's a masculine man and then,
but everybody is okay as long as they respect you and they're kind to each
other.
But the problem is we associate certain behaviors and characteristics with
either negativity or hedonism or a toxic masculinity or someone being a bitch as
a man.
And that's,
these generalizations are often way more harmful and just it's just too
convenient and easy and lazy.
Yeah,
there is no simple way.
And when I think about my own attitudes in this area,
there is a degree of complexity because I've got young daughters,
I've got a two year old and a one year old.
Right.
And there you know daughters so like,
but when they have a day,
cause I'm staying in Los Angeles,
Gabby,
she's Mexican.
She used to,
but when I first moved out here and lived my entourage lifestyle,
she used to look after the house and she used to think like,
oh my baby,
my baby,
she loved me so night.
Like I'll take a matriarchal figure wherever I can find one.
And Gabby used to look after me.
She adored me and stuff.
I stayed friends with her yesterday.
She come around,
she bought like a,
like what?
I can only describe as a bikini for like my baby daughter like that.
What a two year old that doesn't need like a,
like a bikini like top,
excuse me,
burping on the mic.
I like it.
For me,
I felt like I don't want to put my daughter in that.
That's sort of in a way actualizing the like that child and like covering so and
also a lot of the time like with my daughter,
I don't live with my wife,
particularly if our first child I'm like don't dress her up in little dresses
and stuff because she won't be out to run around.
And I thought my God,
I'm not,
that's not that different from like the cliche of a male parent.
That one it at sun and I didn't want to sign or Beano in particular.
I love this kid,
I love this kid regarding,
you know,
it doesn't mean I love having the door,
the door her,
but like I am aware that these things of like dress child this way,
dress a girl this way.
Our constructs fervor to what we were talking about again before by Michelle
Fuko.
We've got a lot done before we went live man.
But when we have to Graham,
Michel Foucault,
what he exposes a lot is that there and a delusion Jill,
Gilda lose is that a lot of things that we take for granted is be normal or
actually constructs.
When I say a child's bikini of it,
there's no reason for any child of any sex or gender to be wearing a bloody
bikini.
So a child with tits is a terrifying idea for for all,
but a very small and terrifying percentage of the population.
So like that is an example of the external feminization of a child.
Like say when there's an argument of feminist argument of,
you know,
gender is a construct.
I can see,
oh yeah,
it's what point is there is there are constructs.
You cannot be like,
my opinion is you can't argue with biology.
Chromosomes are doing what they're doing in the physical realm.
But like a I,
you know,
like being a father to a daughter has made me feel like I don't obviously,
and I know you have daughters or at least they thought three,
$3.
Like I like,
I'm certainly very aware of,
I don't want to push them down some culturally prescribed avenue,
whether it's about their dress,
their sexuality or anything.
So I've got,
you know,
where do I,
where am I on that dial?
You know?
Yeah.
You've got to just not put any pressure on them and let them enjoy their life
and let them find their path.
That's what it's weird.
It's weird,
right?
It's like I see people,
they're,
you know,
they're getting their,
their daughters to dress very,
very feminine with a little mini skirts and stuff when they're five years old
and high heel shoes.
I've seen little kids with high heel shoes.
It seems very strange to me.
I don't like it.
Yeah.
What,
so,
you know,
but for me,
that is being sourced from like co we can extrapolate that to,
well then why should a 20 year old woman wear high heels?
I mean,
I've read cultural analysis.
I'm sure you have have labile.
The lipstick is to emphasize the lips because it's redolent of the vagina.
The high heels is to make a woman seemed more vulnerable and to accentuate
aspects of body shape.
And then these can be,
you know,
seen as evidence of the influence of Patriarchy there.
That there's loads of areas where I feel like,
why are we looking for shit to argue about in this area?
We're just human beings.
Most of us,
the most important people in our life up of the earth,
the diff or a different gender or sex to us.
You know,
why are we live for arguments?
But I can,
you can see the influence of cultural forces that are,
you know,
not neutral.
Yeah,
you certainly can,
but I think it should be up to the choice of the person once they're an adult.
The real problem is putting pressure on them to dress one way or another and not
letting them find their place.
But if a woman becomes,
you know,
whatever age you decide and she wants to wear high heels and a skirt because she
likes the way it looks like there's nothing wrong with that either.
Are are the demonization of sexuality is also a problem.
You know the,
yes.
It is almost as much of a problem as people who will pray upon vulnerable
people.
The the peep people,
people that think there's something wrong with being sexually attractive or
something wrong with being desirable or wanting to be desirable.
There's nothing wrong with that either and that kind of suppression to
suppression of these feelings that you have and this desire that you have,
it's very unhealthy as well.
It's a normal thing to want to be sexual.
It's a normal thing to want to look good.
If a girl looks good in a skirt,
a skirt and high heels and she likes to dress like that,
who the fuck is anyone to saying there's anything wrong with that?
There's nothing wrong with it.
It's if that's what she likes,
that's fun.
Which is what's interesting to me is particularly in really progressive
ideology.
They look down upon women who wear short skirts and high heels and a lot of
makeup and you know open tops that show their boobs.
I guess they think that it's,
they're playing into the patriarchy or the,
there's somehow or another falling into these gender traps,
but yet they celebrate that in transgender people they celebrate that and Trans
men that transitioned to women and then they,
they they really doll it up.
Then they'll like you go girl.
Then they're celebrating the fact that this person is embracing these
traditional aspects of womanhood.
Like you see that a lot with you know,
people that are celebrating Trans Women.
So I find it very fascinating.
The aesthetics of a,
that sort of what would be perhaps could be referred to you with sexualized
dress or like a,
I suppose in males expression expressive or garish clove in jewelry,
tattoos and I understand in British culture that these are often indicators of
class that like that it's typically the lower down the Clo class structure you
are,
the more likely you are to dress in a way that is exhibit if or like you know
women from a blue collar background dress in ways that are exposing,
revealing men have Larry cars and lots of tattoos and jewelry,
expressive ways of demonstrating wealth.
The higher you go up the class,
the more subtle and more dressed down,
you know,
labels or that sort of stuff.
You know.
So in British culture there's a different system of like a different system for
referencing it.
I wonder how that works in American culture with its sort of like it's evident
and match,
discuss racial divisions like certain things.
It seems like a subtle subtle way of condemning particular types of womanhood
that may not just be sourced from dress this way for the male gaze.
It can also be a way of saying dressing that way as an indication of a lower
class background or of a particular type of ethnicity.
But there's also the
reality of males and females is there's a lot of fucking jealous people and
there's a lot of women that just don't have the type of physical body that looks
good in a short skirt with high heels and you know,
a low cut shirt and they don't like when they see it in other women because they
don't,
they're not comfortable with their own bodies there that there's a reality of
that.
I mean,
women get as much or more hate from women as they ever do for men.
And it particularly if women find you to be too overtly sexual with the way you
dress or behave,
that you're,
you're,
you know,
you're damaging male,
female relationships,
you're damaging the dynamic particular office dynamics.
If there's one girl in the office that likes to tramp it up,
you know,
and she's a,
and all the guys are paying attention to her,
women will get mad at her.
I am did a interview a while go where I sort of talked about like pet parent in
our kids,
me and my wife,
how we parent our kids and I said like,
uh,
you know,
it goes well,
I'll have to be on a smart boy if he's much the more dominant parent.
She's much more practical than I am.
Right.
And like stuff that got that got like really negatively written about people
centered black.
I go,
she changes more diapers the night and stuff.
Right.
And then I said,
look,
I don't change diapers or whatever.
It's just my wife,
you know,
regardless of our respective sexes is the more efficient dominant parents.
She's much more likely with light with me.
If my dog goes,
I want that chocolate.
The answer to for me is okay,
all right.
You know,
like,
like I can't bear it.
I see the,
the resistance,
the emotional explosion.
I concede much too early.
I tap out very quickly with my two year old.
My wife is much more now that it's played a long game that's bring up a child.
It's not governed by impulse is like you and I spoke in fact to that gap or
motto that expert on addiction and he's amazing and he says,
because of your own anxiety and pain from your own childhood with no disrespect
to my magnificent parents,
uh,
like you can't andall seeing your kid suffer so you'd like straight away you
bail and do what she wants and stuff.
Now they have like,
so there's so much complexity in the reality of our personal little domestic
relationship and I'm certainly will not saying and everyone else should run
their household in that manner as well.
So help me God,
any man that changes it or you know,
but the way it's reported is like,
that's what happens.
I think in modern media.
It's like change what you say,
then you have to defend what they said.
You sit on that and what I meant,
I'd like,
you know,
I'm not saying that because my wife is a woman,
she should take more domestic duties.
I'm just saying that in our household she seems to have a set of attributes and
characteristics that make her take control of that aspect of parenting.
And it's like the,
the desire to judge,
condemn an object is the priority as opponents to,
you know,
no one's looking to go on.
It's new cares or what you know,
well,
it's also that they're doing it publicly,
so they're doing it most,
I mean,
if you're either reading comments or you're reading articles and if you're
reading articles,
they're just looking for something to be upset about their watch you,
and they'll say,
okay,
this is this a viable target?
Yes,
we got confirmation what he said about changing diapers or his wife being a
better parent is a viable target.
Let's go after him.
And then they just formulate some bullshit argument about who you really are
based on what might have been a throw away or a concession to your wife or even
just a compliment to your wives will come to the self deprecating to yourselves.
Yeah.
But it doesn't,
people don't,
they're not looking at things rationally.
They're just looking at targets.
It's P,
particularly people that write articles,
you know,
what's the best article?
It's gotta to be negative.
Like one of the things that came out of all this a Facebook algorithm stuff is
you find out that Facebook realize somewhere early on that the way to encourage
engagement is to get people upset.
They get way more
engaged and they go back and forth and an inner interact with these posts way
more.
If they're upset,
then they do.
If they agree with it,
if they agree with it,
they might give it a like or a thumbs up and say,
hey,
that's great and that's it.
That's where it ends.
But if you know someone's talking about,
you know,
we shouldn't build the wall,
we should let everyone in.
And you put that on some fucking Trump guys page and they ah,
it's crazy.
I mean you will get thousands and thousands and thousands of interactions.
And so Facebook realized that the way to keep people,
and you know,
they could claim that,
that it's an algorithm and the algorithm just supports whatever the people were
really interested in.
But what they're interested in is conflict.
That demonstrates my earlier point,
which I made up on the spot.
Yeah.
Ai is not a neutral thing.
It is resourced from human perspectives and cause that is a type of AI and that
was not as complex as right now what we're going to experience,
and I can't even imagine,
but what I'm saying is,
is it still die a one,
I want to say resourced from a human,
from a human perspective.
And yes,
of course we are evolved to respond more strongly to negativity than positivity
for loads of reasons.
And I think that's where we can stitch back to what we were saying about taking
personal responsibility for who you are.
Like that.
None of us after sit on Social Media Guy,
I'm fuck you.
Fuck you.
I,
you know,
none of us have to do that.
We can try and resolve though.
I respect that some people don't have any other outlets.
They don't have the privileges I have of being out go,
uh,
support groups where people openly talk about it.
This is the ways that I felt inferior today.
This is the ways that I'm trying to become a better man.
And a better father and a backhoe worker,
you know,
like a lot of people aren't afforded those environments and probably the best
shot they got is having a go is that with someone online and those people,
you know in a way deserve love and sympathy.
But until we on some level recognize that we can all are our own behaviors,
we can all are our own consciousness.
All right.
I don't see how there's going to be,
well at least then we can create a terrain upon which a better,
better systems can start to flourish.
Do you read comments?
No.
I actually like,
ah,
I'm too sensitive.
I can just about manage to listen to people's replies to my conversation.
Like,
you know,
like,
so like,
yeah,
I don't go on to like,
I have a,
like I work with someone who does my social media and like she,
she gives me stuff like,
hey,
respond to these things.
Put some output on that because I don't,
uh,
I don't want to engage with that.
I don't want to like walk up and down any street and knocking on the dog.
And do you like me?
Do you like me to you like me?
I don't.
I don't want to deal with people's responses in various conditions.
Well,
it's also much like the articles,
the way people get a response out of you or the way to people to get your
reaction is to say something really negative.
You look at some,
sometimes when people are not that savvy when it comes to social media,
one thing is that one of the things that you'll notice is they'll interact,
and I've been guilty of this in the past before I sort of realized what I was
doing.
You would only respond to negative things.
I think people were arguing with people.
Meanwhile,
people are saying nice things to you and you ignore them.
Yeah.
It's cause you don't,
don't you add a certain level,
you don't have the physical time.
It doesn't exist to respond to everyone.
It's not possible.
If you get 13,000 comments on one of your posts,
how the fuck does anyone have time to respond to 13,000 people?
You can't.
And then you have email and you have Twitter and Facebook and Instagram and it's
just,
there's no way it's,
there's not enough time in this world.
So you would pass me would've responded to things that cause the more visceral,
I saw someone saying something that was untrue but like fuck you this on true.
But then I realize like what do you,
why are you doing?
Like this is a new thing for people.
There's never been a time where people have had this instantaneous interaction
with people unfiltered on moderated globally.
Yeah.
It's very strange to,
to be able to do that and to be able to go back and forth and just,
Eh,
just to be able to give your comments on things,
to be able to talk about things and it's very addictive to people.
Yeah,
that's right.
And that's why I'm very cautious with it.
I have to sort of sell my life out.
Like I'm essentially a monk in a marriage.
That's basically where I live.
Get up,
meditate,
do yoga,
do
exercises,
do things that are positive for you.
Watch the way that you're thinking.
I'm interested in where again,
in with your own,
do you feel uh,
connected to the person you were as an adolescent?
Did you notice it in your own parent in,
do you know,
is it in the type of choices you make because their image,
I have a view from the outside is like that you have literally built something
for yourself.
You operate within it and you are quite protected and you are independent and
not forced to deal with too many negative outside influences by an unavoidable
dynamics that unnecessary dynamics like uh,
you know,
as a father and dealing with colleagues and stuff like that.
Do you experience a lot of tension,
anxiety?
What,
what,
what has happened to that guy?
Do you feel that you have transcended that?
Cause I do in my own life feel like,
yeah.
After I'm not the adolescent boy was.
I've like,
you know,
I've learned from that and I still in a very sort of cold psychological way.
Yeah.
When I'm doing a Hubiera,
that's their g Bjj classes I'm doing over here.
We have professor Ricardo Wilkies,
amazing guy.
Like when I'm,
when I'm doing those classes,
I have caught a sense of fathering my child self of like,
you know,
cause I weren't doing those kinds of things when I was a kid.
I'm like,
so all right Russell,
we're just in a Bjj class and it's a panic there to impress anybody,
right.
Just do.
If you don't know,
just ask.
I've got a voice in myself because I chat to Tony Robbins,
you know,
he's like a number obviously high achieving guy who I admire and respect a great
deal and like,
you know when he talks he does like these cold plunges and he says before I get
in that project that you're getting in that fucking punch and I keep telling us,
my God,
I don't talk to myself.
I was like,
Ryan Russell,
we're going to get in the cold plan.
Should we going to let you know by,
I have to talk to myself.
Jenny,
what are you doing with that aspect of yourself?
Do you still have a relationship with it?
How was it like when you're doing all these psychedelic cosmic Nordic
explorations of the psyche,
are you not encountering aspects of to on if undeveloped and addressed?
There's always going to be unaddressed and undeveloped aspects of yourself.
But I'm very,
very,
very different to who I was when I was a young boy.
I mean,
um,
I'm not 100% self actualized.
I don't think anybody is,
but I'm just a totally different human being.
I remember it,
but I remember it with humor.
Like I remember a laugh.
I'm like,
wow,
so silly.
I was so weird back then.
And uh,
you know,
with life experience and developing confidence and understanding of who you are
and why you have those feelings and why you were insecure and why he had so much
self doubt,
martial arts helped me with that,
with that tremendously because it was the first thing that I ever did where I
didn't feel like a loser.
So the first thing that I ever did where people like respected me and they liked
me for it,
you know,
I'm like,
wow,
this is like,
there was a feeling that I was completely unused to in the 14 previous years of
my life.
All of a sudden there was this,
this feeling that I was unusual.
I was unique,
I was special.
Wow.
Yeah.
It was appreciated.
A good,
a quick,
yeah,
I was,
I had a natural inclination towards it and then I was obsessed with it,
so I was obsessed with this.
I was training every day,
all day long,
and then my instructor recognized it really early on,
so he allowed me to train there for free and just I would teach classes and
teaching classes helped me a lot as well because when you're teaching,
you're breaking down techniques and you're you,
you,
when you're showing someone how to do it,
you really cementing those pathways in your own mind.
Yeah,
yeah,
that's right.
That must be an important step on the road to mastery.
I see that clip where Eddie Bravo gave you your black belt and he were very
moved by that.
Like,
so for me that like moments like that,
it must connect you to the beginning of the journey.
Yeah,
that does.
for sure.
And it would still,
you know,
the,
the journey of Jujitsu is a fascinating one because unless your,
someone who's,
you know,
a Salahi Barrow or John Jacques Machado or it's just a true master who's
dedicated their entire life to it,
the journey is so long,
it's so long.
It's like if you're a guy who runs you like to run,
I like to run a mile three or four days a week,
no big deal.
But then,
you know,
your next door neighbor is an ultra marathon runners preparing for them the Moab
to 40 where he's going to run 240 miles.
Yeah.
You're just,
you're never going to catch up the same amount of times and you should always
defer to that person when you have questions about running.
And that's how it is with Jujitsu.
Like is,
you know,
yeah,
I'm a black belt,
but I'm not a black belt.
Like John Jacques Machado is a black belt is a,
there's levels to even to that.
So I always have questions so the journey's never over.
It's always long.
There's always a better way to get out of an arm bar or a better way to set up a
triangle or whatever it is.
There's the,
one of the beautiful things about Jujitsu is that it's so complex.
There's so many variables,
there's so many situations and interactions and exchanges and entries and
defenses and and and way to chain moves together.
And the the correct to set something up
to three steps ahead to know that if you grab the lapel this way,
the guy's going to try to shake it off that way and that exposes this,
which exposes that.
And then the next defense will expose this and then you keep going and going and
going and going until you get them.
It's so beautiful to watch that because it's like as if there's a preexisting
net or grid of interrelated signs that we'll work together and like as a white
belt,
I've got three stripes now.
I was like,
thanks.
I was really hoping that by the time I came back on air,
I'd have a blue belt and that could be closing in on it.
I'm on a train,
I'm training free times a week privates and I'm attending two classes and what
I've done.
That's great.
Thanks a lot and was a significant step for me is like now in the classes when
I'm sparring,
people are,
don't try just in the handshake to manipulate them into go in easy.
How'd you look?
So lovely.
Oh Ralphie,
go then
please try to manipulate people.
Yeah,
like just a subtle gesture or something like that.
Right,
right,
right.
Just trying to take it easy on me.
Don't hurt me.
Come on,
let go.
Ah.
Avoid big people.
Yeah.
Sometimes like I try and stay down that white belt ended a room,
but like now the more I do it,
like the more they coax me up near great.
Big giant men,
like a lightness,
a guide.
I got like,
they've sort of ones up out it like the hard end of purple belt and above Dave
pull Busby and like there's people like their hands and their feet look
different to my hands and feet as different than their hands and feet.
It was different from mine is mine are to my daughters and I feel like,
how am I supposed to ever do anything with these people?
Like hard water,
like drowning in hard water,
the way they move and fold around me and I will just,
the was boasted do and my breathing goes.
Yeah.
But the finis with other white belts is that,
uh,
what I feel is like there is,
my ego comes back in because there I feel like,
no,
I should be getting something.
The first time I've got choked out by another white belt I was,
I felt like I went into a room I'd not been in since I was 16 getting my ass
kicked in,
in bus stops,
you know,
and stuff.
I felt like I was quiet for 24 hours just sitting and reflecting or no shit.
And that just be done with it.
Like I said,
this is a combat sport.
This happens.
You're going to experience why,
right.
So it doesn't mean I'm a bad person that I've failed a no.
You're going to have to get used to that.
If you're going to be is humiliation.
You get used to defeat,
but it's,
it's that humble
cooling is very good for you.
You know,
I've been,
I don't know how many times I've been tapped out in my life,
but it's probably more than a thousand.
Probably thousands.
No,
the,
yeah,
there.
Uh,
so you sit there while I'll tell you about Jujitsu and the other and the other
thing that's been good about it,
it's like when it is the other way,
like I remember like a guide,
it was a big guy on top of me and like I was,
he,
he was in mount right.
Like he won't actually applying a submission,
but there's just the sheer discomfort of having someone there.
Their body,
their sweat,
their head,
abdomen,
their reproductive organs that the justice system to theses in their bow on top
of me.
I just nearly tapped out at,
but then he went to move to get onboarded,
fooled.
Hang on a second.
There's a moment and I managed to escape from that and like the amount of energy
that that releases were like,
fuck you.
That's hilarious
feeling.
It's also very satisfying to to defend against something that someone used to
catch you with.
Like say if someone's a really good at taking your back,
choked you a couple of times,
and then one time they take your back,
but you defend and you get out.
You're like,
I got out.
There's an escape.
I can make this.
I'm getting better.
I love being in the cave.
That meant we'll spice because why?
My technique was,
oh,
I'm not good at that.
Never bother trying.
I'm not good at that kind of stuff.
Never bothered trying.
So for me at this stage in my life to go and do something that I'm not good at
this,
we have other men that is competitive.
They involve so much vulnerability,
failure and learning.
I'm thinking,
well,
you've got growing,
you've got to be growing.
She'll,
you're doing stuff that you never would have done before.
Even turning up at a new place like I'm doing here in la and making those new
relationships and doing that.
You know,
it's amazing for me.
Another thing I into is the integrity of it,
right?
But it was crisp,
clear,
uh,
black belt under Gracie.
Right.
And you came my teacher,
like if he gave me a blue belt that would look good,
man.
He'll be videoed.
I would tweet,
it'll be everywhere.
I'll Russell brand got blue belt is shit,
mass work.
But no,
he doesn't do it out of integrity and respect for that,
you know,
it means more to him evidently then as simply the act of kindness though,
so like what is nice to belong to something that has protected and valuable
systems.
He did say to me,
you keep going by the end of the year blue belt.
I think by like uh,
you know,
it's not dished out like these nice to know that there's some kind of order or
an area where Solibri manipulation,
charm human,
none of those things or redundant.
No,
in Jujitsu it's very protected.
Anyone that gives out a bad belt,
it's very bad for their integrity.
It's the,
the,
the school would lose face so badly in the community and you meet someone who's
a Hicks and Gracie Brown belt,
that mother fucker's a Hicks and Gracie brown belt.
He is as legit as they get.
They don't get any more legit.
Like if you got to that point of Hicks and Gracie gives you a brown belt,
it's just,
it's irrefutable and that's how it should be.
And that's a beautiful thing about the art form is that it has this self
correcting sort of aspect to it that when you roll,
when you spar with each other,
it your ability or lack of is exposed and there's no other way around it.
Yeah,
that's good to not avoid that Tafe,
but you'll be better.
You know,
you're,
you're a fit guy,
you're a healthy guy.
If you just keep going and get off that fucking Vegan Diet and keep going.
I watched a documentary,
um,
called
what the health,
have you seen it?
It's like,
yeah,
it's filled with a lot of propaganda and got them.
Those guys are getting like the Nazis,
I remember him,
they used a lot of discredited studies and the,
there's a lot of epidemiology studies that'll connect things.
What does that mean?
Like an epidemic?
Well,
you know,
we could pull up what the actual Tom,
Jamie pulled something out in the algae.
But the way I would describe it as,
they would do these studies and essentially it would be,
they would,
they would ask you what you eat on a daily basis.
How often do you mean?
How,
and it's basically a survey.
And in,
in that survey they would say,
well,
there's a direct correlation between people that eat meat and diabetes.
So let's pull up the definition.
But the problem is what is causing here a branch of medicine,
which deals with incidents,
distribution and possible control of diseases and other factors relating to
health.
Um,
so when they're,
when they're dealing with incidents,
right?
They're dealing with,
uh,
how often do you eat red meat?
How often do you eat this,
how often you eat that?
And then they find,
oh,
well there's more instances of diabetes and people that eat meat.
Okay,
but is it people that eat meat and vegetables or is it people that eat meat and
vegetables and diet coke and,
and sugary sodas and ice cream and French fries.
And how are they eating their meat or their eating cheeseburgers for some
bullshit fast food place.
Are they eating grass fed steak,
eating grass fed steak and vegetables.
And there's very little evidence that shows there's anything wrong with eating
meat.
If you follow a normal healthy,
what they would call primal diet,
cut out all the grains,
cut out all the sugar,
cut out all the bullshit,
eat vegetables and meat.
And there's almost nothing.
I mean the less you have some very unusual,
rare condition where you are either allergic to meat or you have some very
strange uh,
digestive system where you find you have allergies to it or you have real
problems digesting it or you have real problems with high cholesterol foods,
which is very rare as well.
Most of what you're getting is vegan propaganda.
People that want other people to be convinced that the way that they're living
as the correct way and that eating meat is,
is physically bad for you and it's causing all these harms.
What's causing all the harm for people physically is the modern American diet.
And that's been pretty established.
Yes,
that's right.
And that there are clear ethical reasons to be Vegan in the,
it takes you out of the exploitation of animals.
But that documentary,
what the health that I watched was like an hour,
not be a vegetarian for years and this light and I've gone back and forth to
veganism because I felt God Jesus Christ,
man,
there's enough things in my life I'm not doing without not being at.
I have an egg without feeling guilty for pasture raised eggs.
If you get them from a good farm,
the chickens are just hanging out chickens in my God and they'll confident in
these animals.
And the one by one,
slowly my dog to eliminate in
Tampa for last,
nine of them to coyotes just last month,
maybe two months
ago.
That's a pretty heavy.
So it was a heavy toll.
Yeah.
Well we had a fire out here and the chicken coop burnt down.
We've got a smaller chicken coop and the coyotes figured out how to get into it
when we're at home.
And we came home to just feathers everywhere.
It was disgusting.
Brutal.
They're brutal little monsters.
It's coyotes.
Yeah.
You know,
I'm governable there.
The reason why we don't have rats everywhere too.
All right.
So yeah,
Goliath and don king was right.
So like,
hey though,
um,
the thing about that Vegan documentary mate is there,
it,
it tuned in to my preexisting belief when it said stuff like,
oh,
the diabetes association,
they are funded by these meat and dairy organizations in these pharmaceutical
companies to cancer organizations.
Similarly accepts donations from these organizations.
And it made me recognize like my preexisting idea that I come to it with is like
that whole pyramid of these are the things you should eat,
bread,
milk,
just where the figs that it was easy and cheap to produce and that we're
profitable.
Think that they really did use to think that bread wouldn't and grains are the
most important thing.
You think they felt that?
I think they did.
I think they thought it was,
it was filling and it provided energy and I don't think they understood well.
There was no talk of gluten intolerance when we were young.
It didn't exist and there was no understanding of excess carbs and excess carbs
leads to excess body weight and it makes,
it makes you store fat.
People didn't think about it that way.
They didn't understand it.
There was,
the thing about nutrition is in nutrition,
science is a,
it's a body of knowledge that's constantly added to yeah,
I'm in fact pat,
it's,
most things are,
who knows what misapprehensions and ignorance.
We toil.
And that will be revealed with,
do you do any,
uh,
I feel like I've heard you talk about hormone stuff.
Yeah.
I do hormone replacement therapy.
What type of things?
Testosterone and human growth hormone.
You have to give yourself a jap and now you get in the thigh,
thigh,
you won't do the arts apps and put pride.
That's for Mrs Rogan
touch that.
It ties right there.
It's easy to grab when you're putting your ass.
It's just like an awkward two.
Farmable um,
yeah,
but they also have,
um,
taking whole light.
So you're taking growth hormone,
you're not noticed any negative side effects or you get your blood monitored.
You know,
when you,
when you're doing something like that.
This,
this is also if you're a person that has addictive problems,
addiction problems,
which I don't necessarily have them as much with substances,
but um,
uh,
well you saw with video games when you got here at the video game problem that I
have match that dark room.
You and your party sway and pie.
I didn't baffled by the real world one to um,
martial arts.
I've been addicted to martial arts.
I've been addicted to playing pool.
I get addicted to getting good at things.
I get it very addicted to things.
If there's something that I get obsessed with,
like Jujitsu or whatever it is,
I get obsessed and that's all I think about all day long.
I just had,
I just,
you know,
it's not healthy,
but with hormones,
you want to make sure that you don't overdose yourself.
You want to make sure that you stay within a very narrow range where your,
you know your,
you have what are the healthy levels of a person that's in their late twenties
that's really what you want.
You don't want to have hyper human levels,
which some people do do
hyper human.
You're going to create a nod ecosystem.
You're fucking up your body,
man.
You're just jolting yourself with all this extra shit.
He about to take this sweet lady thyroid.
Is that part of your system?
Yeah.
I have 'em.
I take Armour thyroid is actually made from pigs.
Thyroids.
Do you mean pigs?
Five relate to now hold on a minute.
What's happened to the pig?
Dead.
They're long gone.
They're not so stressful.
Rev or lack of thei really teetering about all emasculated.
Well,
this is like,
so yeah,
I'm interested in this hormone stuff.
I'm interested in that,
but you know me,
I've got to be very,
very like cautious about Moodle or in stuff.
But if you have the exercise regimen that you're talking about,
I don't think you're gonna have got to get that blue pill.
I'm going to do what it takes.
Yeah,
bring me the thigh right out of it directly.
You should eat eggs though,
man.
You really should.
You should eat.
You should eat some animal protein without,
I mean,
if you oppose the moral aspect of killing an animal,
which I totally understand and appreciate,
and that's what led me to become a hunter in the first place,
is that I was really uncomfortable watching these animal rights videos of
factory farming.
I thought it was disgusting.
I'm just like,
I don't want to participate in this.
It's reprehensible.
Hunting's a different thing.
Men.
To me,
hunting is this intense.
It's very spiritual in a way.
I mean people don't get it because they see you celebrating when it's over
because it's very,
very,
very difficult to close in on a wild animal in mostly elk.
Well elks,
my favorite for two reasons.
One,
it's very delicious,
super nutritious.
Also,
if I shoot one elk,
I could eat it for like eight months.
Well freezing and freezing them breathing out.
Stalking and elk on the plains.
Where are you let near where you live.
You just go to,
are you Charles Grant Travel?
Yeah.
Well you do travel on bikes.
If you a white tail hunt,
a lot of times she would go into the woods with bikes cause they don't leave a
scent the way your feet do,
you know?
And um,
animals don't associate the sound of a bike the way they associate it with like
the sound of stepping bipedal
hominid stepping towards evolve Ip.
Yeah.
They see you on a bike.
They didn't even freak out as much.
Delightful.
Never seen that before.
What's that Brian?
What are these things?
Yeah.
Elk or they like herd animals sees,
you see like a herd.
Yeah.
You see her
heard of them.
And to try to figure out which way the wind's blowing.
And you tried to get close to them.
Is this a video of us?
Yeah,
video house from a beautiful place.
I mean
that's an elk now the thing is you've me,
I see
that elk there and I saw a feel like a silver.
I've watched too much Disney.
Um,
you know,
like I see that elk and I feel like I'm Bambi literally,
like I don't have it.
Like is that early in the morning?
You look tired?
Not Tired.
My now late afternoon actually.
Can you tell those late afternoon?
Yeah.
Like say it like I have from that position I couldn't like I would love the game
of being able to him cause actually I've had to go down.
Gun Range is,
it turns out I'm pretty good shot and it's nice to see that thing come back.
We've like holes around his abdomen and his head satisfied there.
You've been dealt with paper man,
but,
but like the elk I couldn't,
I've got too much empathy in me that I couldn't deal with the feeling of after
it was shot.
I like it,
almost thinking about it,
the sentimentality of it.
I've sentimentalize it now,
you know,
at least I don't eat me and stuff like that.
So it's not like I have all those feelings of but can handle it in a packaged
portioned off way.
Yeah.
It's just I feel too much like,
oh,
that creature.
So what in your Ed,
when you're doing it,
when you're pulling the trigger,
you're not having what's going on in your mind.
Well,
you,
you only are hunting these mature animals that have already passed on their
genes.
You also are recognizing that if you are not killing these things,
they're not,
it's not like they're going to live forever.
Right.
They are.
They live a short life,
a short life with a very violent death.
It's either wolves or mountain lions or bears or something's going to take them
out.
Yeah.
And what you're doing is essentially dipping your toe into the natural world.
And I've heard the argument that,
well,
this is ridiculous because everyone can't do that.
You know,
if everyone went out and hunted all the animals,
so would be no animal slept.
Which is true.
But,
um,
I'm not everyone,
so I don't,
I'm going to use that if everyone did it.
Argument
argument because you,
you,
if you're encouraging people to hunt,
it is kind of a good argument because it's not realistic.
It's not sustainable.
But the other thing to recognize is that the reason why most of this wildlife
exists in the first was a lot of it was wiped out in the early 20th century from
um,
what they call market hunting.
And the late,
late 19th century,
early 20th century,
um,
they,
you know,
they didn't have refrigeration and,
uh,
it was hard to get food and we didn't have the same sort of large scale
agriculture that we have today.
And so when someone would want meat,
they would,
uh,
someone who would either have to hunt it for you and you would go to the market
and get that hunted food or a,
you would go out and do it yourself.
And they basically wiped out most of the wildlife in North America to the point
of extinction.
Whitetail deer,
elk,
they've been extirpated from the majority of their range in North American,
only been replaced.
And a few other places,
but the places would they be been replaced.
It's all through money that was generated through hunting tags all through
billions and billions of dollars.
There's a thing called the a Robertson Pickman I think that's it's called act,
where a 10% if you buy hunting gear and equipment,
10% of that money goes to habitat restoration.
Um,
making sure that a rangers and forest people get funded.
So there's a fishing game,
department gets funded and all of,
and also population conservation,
making sure that the populations are healthy,
repopulating certain areas with elk and deer.
And this has all been done through the money that's generated through hunting.
Yeah,
I can see that.
There's an looking at my own feelings towards it.
I can see that there's potentially,
I'm bringing a sentimentality to the idea of animals that's like amp for upper
morphic.
Yes.
Like I'm not,
oh,
you can't kill that.
It will abide.
It's babies.
And I mean like thinking about things like that.
Um,
but will I,
you know,
I live in a rural area in Britain where like hunt in is normal and I wouldn't
and agriculture is normal and I wouldn't get very far if I were sort of like you
can't shoot those pheasants,
look at their feathers,
they're beautiful.
And I mean like it wouldn't,
it's not a health whatchu say whilst I like record in my cell,
I couldn't do that because like I don't,
it messes me up on a sort of,
feels like a very sort of deep visceral level,
you know,
like,
but I feel that this is precisely the kind of territory where we have to look at
acknowledging and tolerate indifference between us.
This is where I feel like there's sort of these ossified polarized positions
between right and left are starting to take root because if someone like me who
don't eat meat,
don't eat animal products and wouldn't hunt for ethical reasons,
starts trying to impose on other people now you shouldn't harm because if they
start having not watched Bambi,
you know,
like that's going to mean that people aren't able to explore who they are.
And so my po,
I've let go of judging people around things that I don't agree with because I
reckon I know everything.
You know what I mean?
I'm this,
this is,
this is about my morality is about how I behave and if people said to me,
I'm thinking about going hunting,
I go,
well,
these are my feelings about it.
However,
though I just heard that it's hunting does contribute apparently to the survival
of some species and there is an argument that it's quite natural and indigenous
and it's probably a way of getting in contact with who we are.
It regionally as hunt in people.
It's an important part of our anthropological history and possibly a lot of the
condemnation of hunting is part of the rejection of who we used to be is we
become overly civilized and more and more detached from what it is to be human.
Whether that's sacred or pragmatic.
We don't know what human beings are anymore.
We reject her own sexuality.
We reject our own bodies.
We reject,
you know,
we're trying to turn ourselves in these sort of cyborgs,
these emotionless,
sexless,
meaningless creatures.
Where is our passion,
where is our connection with the sacred?
They would go,
hold on.
Only after about hunting.
When are you going to stop talking?
Never gave me an,
in Palmer we were with my belief system on all things like I,
so I don't feel like it ain't where again,
a judging people by.
Like I,
I'm interested as well with this.
I keep bringing up the subject of DMT.
Like what?
I guess what I want to know about is like,
cause I,
I'm,
you know,
obviously a person in recovery,
I don't drink,
I don't take drugs,
haven't done for a long time and are recognized for certain people.
They can't do it safely.
Psychedelics and hallucinogens,
it seemed to me exist in a realm outside of that because they're not about,
they're not pleasure seeking.
There's like seem to me like it's a spiritual portal.
However,
I'm a crafty bastard when it comes to this stuff and I'm always looking for an
in,
you know,
when I see your cannabis treasure trove over there.
I mean that is some,
yeah,
as you said,
let Raiders of the lost Ark Stuff and I'm holding in my hand now the CBD rich
cannabis soft gels clasp in it.
You know,
so like I'm saying,
I'm worried that that is a gateway that CVD,
which is not necessarily psychoactive psychoactive.
It's not,
but it does help you with anxiety.
It helps a lot of people because it alleviates a lot of inflammation which tends
to have a corresponding impact on,
on your anxiety.
How do I say this says here,
11 milligrams of THC.
Does that mean,
I mean it says THC.
It does say that the ponds are probably a wonder one.
There's the one to one or ed tech 18 to one or 11.
It says there's an 1,101 has a couple of different ones in that box.
Oh,
I give you,
almost give you the wrong one.
Pack a snack.
Don't take that.
This one goes back in this one.
This one's way more powerful than you seem to seem very relaxed and free from
anxiety.
I will say that.
Um,
but like,
so like what I suppose I'm interested in because I listen,
I meditate in the whole lot.
I meditate a lot.
I'm doing all these things.
I mean I experiencing transcendent states,
I'm experiencing what it's like to not feel attached to my identity as Russell,
who are you before?
You are Russell,
who are you before you identify yourself as a man in England,
who are you?
Who is the person who is the consciousness?
Who is the awareness?
And when I listened to say Terence Mckenna talking about his experiences in
Psychedelia as such lamp and we've certainly,
we've seen entity and we've so many philosophical connotations and the way that
he uses the information he's getting from hallucinogenics experiences to
speculate on how we should organize society,
what it,
what the implications are for freedom.
He's refusal to accept that there are certain kinds of experiences that should
be prohibited.
That it's ridiculous.
The adults should be prevented from having that.
I,
I'm fascinated.
I'm also,
I suppose part of my bias is I love anything that gets me out of my head.
I feel a tremendous sense of relief,
whether it's through meditation or even sports or sex being relieved of the
burden of the constantly thinking mind.
But when I hear like those,
um,
Vivian IX descriptions of DMT realm or our West era,
I think something in the hungers for that hungers for it.
Do you worry that you're trying to get intoxicated?
You were,
that you're,
but you're trying to find a loophole.
Yeah,
cause I am doing that.
I'm really
looking for a loophole.
It's like I'm going around like a sort of a trash lawyer looking for some way to
get into.
Is there,
hold on a second.
What about this crash lawyer?
That's a great way of putting it.
Yeah.
I mean I know people that have problems with addiction that have done
psychedelics and didn't have a problem,
but I'm sure some people have had problems and I don't know about them.
DMT is interesting in that,
first of all,
it's very quick.
The experiences only about 15 minutes,
20 minutes Max.
And it's also,
it's not necessary.
It's not an intoxicant and the way that you would think about traditionally you
are still you in the face of this experience.
And I think,
I think it's some sort of a chemical gateway.
That's what I think.
I think there's a gateway in your mind that can lead to some other dimension
that's probably there all the time.
If there is a,
uh,
omnipresent continually existing realm that human beings aren't accessing
because of that particular buyer,
chemical formulation of consciousness as it is in this point in our evolution
and that we can get there.
And it seems as like,
you know,
I've heard Terence Mckenna say it's more real,
it's more real.
There's stuff in there,
you know,
and excuse me.
And when he talks about them beings,
you know,
like the,
he describes herself dribbling basketballs,
creating life Faberge egg like an I device.
He's through vibration and there to see it,
to do it.
I never saw it.
It's called the machine elves.
He's called them all sorts of different things.
The way I've described them is there the geometric patterns made out of love and
understanding,
say the cmos.
So you've read,
you can look at a geometrical pattern and read meaning into it.
It had an emotional quality.
They're made out of something and they move,
they change like they don't stay what they are.
They're constantly evolving in front of you into something more and more
beautiful.
It's very weird.
What did it make you feel
like?
I knew nothing.
That was the most profound aspect.
All of the stuff that you concentrate on everyday is nonsense and there is some
other thing that's connected that's probably influencing this world and it's
probably what people see when they have near death experiences.
The depictions of the afterlife.
I mean that's probably what it all is and religious experience is when profits
are talking about,
oh my God,
I went into this railroad.
There's these beings.
They've told me we're all one.
We cover scholars in Jerusalem or connecting Moses,
his experience with the burning Bush to the acacia tree,
Acacia tree,
which is rich and DMT.
The burning Bush is with God was to Moses and that through this burning Bush,
he came out with these 10 commandments of how people should live their lives.
I mean that easily could have been just a very convoluted sort of translation of
a DMT trip suddenly.
And also when you think of it,
certainly there are archetype or images that seem to be repeated throughout
ancient cultures aren't an archaic stories that seem to refer to the potential
plant experience is to affect consciousness.
Even the garden of Eden do not eat of the fruit of the tree of knowledge,
otherwise you will become as gods,
you know,
uh,
like I sensed that now if,
if there is some realm that we can reach through that experience,
but seeing that puts into perspective everything else we experienced on the
material realm.
And that thing seems to,
in your words,
be MNA in love and understanding while ever changing,
completely formless and communicate in love and understanding it for,
I can't help but think that that should become our pri,
Ori,
to have a relationship with that realm and to bring about that experience.
I don't even mean in a literal way.
Cause even terrorism,
Mckenna said there were some people vulnerable selves.
He was probably referring to people like me that probably shouldn't mess around
with that kind of stuff.
Really talking about people's kids,
a friend.
Right.
Which he believed he had,
by the way.
Did he?
Yeah,
he,
he had some very unique perspectives on schizophrenia and the,
the way people interact with the world itself.
I think if we lived in a healthy world,
uh,
healthy civilization that had a healthy relationship with psychoactive
substances,
we'd probably have centers where you would have a legitimate Sharman,
a medical advisor and someone would take you through a guided experience.
We're doing that now with ketamine.
There's a lot of people that are very depressed that are having these physician
controlled ketamine experiences that have had a profound effect on their
depression.
My friend Neil Brennan has gone through several of them and he was the,
he's a comedian,
a very funny comedian.
So when he was describing it,
it was hilarious.
I was going to a doctor's office,
a tripping his fucking balls off,
you know,
and the doctors shooting them up with intermuscular ketamine.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
And he's having these insane,
so yeah,
I go,
so you're having psychedelic experiences like,
oh yeah,
that's driving.
It was really funny.
Um,
I mean tripping his fucking balls off in these whatever states that ketamine,
I've never experienced ketamine.
I don't know what it does,
but it's apparently profoundly hallucinogenic and you have these wild crazy
experiences on it and for whatever reason it has a great impact on depression
for a lot of people.
I think it's a perspective enhancer,
but it also does something to rewire the mind.
Some of these suggest is that mental illness is a response to our material
conditions.
Whether that's,
whether that mentally,
honestly schizophrenia,
depression or addiction people,
look,
I don't hang on a minute this in are we supposed to live?
I took that came in one time towards the end of my using and as usual,
it's not in the right type of environment should be doing stuff like that in a
nightclub.
You need to be under that should manic conditions,
whiteout guy or wherever.
Whoever nominated a shaming.
But I felt like it was like going into a tunnel made of sound and like having to
navigate,
I'll start off,
shit,
I'm still in reality.
Why am I going to do it?
As my self consciousness becomes a noise instead of a string of words and signs
am I'm in a Gad,
his place,
you know?
So like for me it's clear that drugs were never meant to be recreational.
In fact,
they never was.
I was never,
hey man,
this is crazy.
I was always an unfucking pain.
I need some shit there.
Helped me out.
Otherwise I am can probably kill myself,
you know?
So like it was a way of holding that stuff.
Our arms limp.
So I guess my renewed curiosity around DMT in Iowa and Ios,
Gha and other sort of plant medicines and not,
you know that.
Do you know Daniel Pinchbeck and like them guys?
They're sort of part of that.
I'm curious about it cause I guess I'm continually trying to find a way where
someone go,
right,
here's a way where we can do it,
where it's sort of safe.
And I've heard of other people in recovery doing it.
And when I think about what my motivation is,
is when I hear people talking about and my own and my own recollections of
experiencing what felt like God,
and by God I mean a sense of oneness and that my individual identity isn't my
real identity and I'm connected to everything and love is the most important
thing.
You know?
I want a real experience of that so that when I'm out in the world,
I can remember when I'm driving or when I'm dealing with people or if I'm buying
something or if I'm feeling inferior or feeling superior that like you said,
this is bullshit.
This is like a secondary reality.
Don't let it govern you.
You know,
as someone that's been seduced by fame or personal life,
if I get this puns film,
then everyone's going to love me.
Oh,
if this standup set goes well,
you know,
like a person that's placed all of my wellbeing outside of myself,
there's certain knowledge that there is an inner connection that will take care
of you that's accessible.
I guess I'm hungry to sort of feel it in a way that's like,
oh my God,
now there is no doubt.
So in the sense is a crisis of faith,
not crisis psychedelic states that you could achieve without taking anything.
I mean,
you could certainly get there in a flotation tank.
You could get there through holotropic breathing.
I've never done coon Daleney Yoga,
but apparently the people that get really deep into Kundalini Yoga,
you can literally have DMT trips.
I know I have friends that have done DMT and have experienced DMT trips through
Kundalini.
Yeah.
But you have to be really dedicated.
I mean,
there's a lot of time,
a lot of time,
a lot of energy and you have to really understand the methods and follow them to
a t and you can achieve these altered states of consciousness that are
apparently not from my personal experience,
but from people telling me incredibly profound.
Yeah.
I mean I've had comparable things.
I guess it's,
you know,
the difference between feeling something that's that overwhelming that gives you
no choice.
You know like there's like,
it's not like in a Kundalini you've got to do these breast correctly,
you've got to sit,
there you go try again.
He had done quite a bit of Kundalini.
Well what for me it feels like what I've felt quite a lot yoga,
clea and meditatively is a cessation of what I would call my individual
consciousness.
Like,
oh I'm not this,
this isn't who I am.
This is just a temporary experience and all of the value systems of our world
are built upon these primal drives in collaboration with a culture that likes to
stratify people and manage people and operates like a massive farm where it's
easier to keep people
to give our operating in these kinds of ways systemically.
I've still felt rushes of that like a certain word.
Less clarity.
If you could imagine me having anything that was wordless even for a moment and
like an in that space.
They is great pace.
So I suppose get what's turning me on about the,
like the DMT in Ios,
caffeine is that the way narrow advised that they are going to meet characters
and stuff like that and it's,
and it's going to be playing and beyond doubt,
you know,
cause I suppose what profit do you know like whether it,
when a profit returns from there,
whether it's the burning Bush or the cave,
they come back and they say all this stuff that you're taking seriously is not
real.
There's this other realm.
Start prioritizing it or you are going to live in hell on earth if you're going
to be governed by your materialistic drives,
your sexual drive and it's going to imprison you.
And it turns out that they're bright as I would like,
you know,
I suppose what I'm after because I'm partly,
on a super like on one level influenced by what you're doing and how you've
created your own light,
your create your own business and your own success.
This symbiosis of stand up and the podcast and like it's become like a sort of a
lifestyle brand in a sense.
Joe.
Like,
you know,
I'm sort of like,
yeah,
I don't,
I don't want to be continually dragged into these color like working within
institutions.
Like,
you know,
I,
I'm over here doing a bloody,
I'm doing ballers and I'm bloody glad to be over here doing ballers and working
with the rock.
And I've got a funny story about that if you want it like a,
um,
but like,
uh,
you know,
like really what interests me is like,
can I be dead?
Can I dedicate my life to humorously,
communicate in spiritual information and indeed starting to live it.
So like that.
And I suppose what that would mean is,
you know,
I'm getting better,
but I'm not a person who's obsessed with porn or sex or drugs or weapons,
like,
you know,
to become it,
to become what you actually are,
to recognize that we're all different.
Your perfect realization of you is going to involve hun in and all of these
things that you've created for your gift.
And that my perfect version of me is going to involve all of this.
And not everyone needs to build sort of empires or entertainment industries or
wherever.
But all of us are on some journey to self actualization and realization.
There's individual as our fingerprints and as natural as a seed turning into a
tree.
And if we don't have a way of accessing that and the one that we're
dissatisfied,
no wonder we're tired.
There's an opioid epidemic,
they want to,
people are bored and angry and lonely.
Well,
I think what you can do is be yourself.
And what you can do is express yourself.
And what you can do is constantly seek to improve and grow and you are doing
those things.
So if you're saying,
can I do these things?
Can I be comedic and spiritual and what you're doing it right.
So what can be done?
So it's don't,
you're doing it,
you know,
it's all just a matter of what,
whether or not your satisfied with your progress and where you are and who you
are and how you express yourself.
So your pursuit for excellence.
When you're saying I've got get better at Bjj or archery or hunting or whatever,
that isn't coupled with a sort of sense
because you're not fucking good enough.
I've got this wonderment.
I love it.
Julie joy in it.
And there's enthusiasm.
I mean,
in everything and archery in particular,
it's very,
you know,
there's that book Zen and the art of archery,
which is a,
it's an interesting book.
Uh,
it's,
you know,
I mean I think there's some really great points to it,
but that state of mind that you get when you release an arrow and that Arrow
perfectly fine,
it's mark really is Zan.
It's,
it requires so much concentration and focus and technique that you really don't
think about other things.
Beautiful.
And it's cleansing and a lot of ways it's mine cleansing.
I find Jujitsu to be very similar in that way too,
that it's so all encompassing.
It's so,
there's so much on the line,
it's so difficult to do that while it's happening.
You're freeing your mind up.
I mean,
I think of video games in the same way and that's bizarre on all of those things
suggest a transmission between the inner and outer world,
isn't it?
You're looking at their bulls eye and then,
oh my God,
I've made this thing traverse time and space.
Or Bjj,
I've been shown again and again how we execute this triangle and I've just
actually done it against resistance.
It's a amazing to feel that it's amazing to feel that that your inner life can
express yourself in the material world,
whatever we'll wherever you're looking to explore that and to test yourself and
when you test yourself and you have to figure your way through something or
change the path because the path you were on was unsuccessful.
When you're doing that,
it's,
it's really good for the mind.
And for the,
I hesitate to say the spirit because I think that word spirituality so beaten
down and abused,
you know what you mean?
It's become commodified.
Yeah.
It's like,
yeah.
It's like when people call themselves a healer,
I'm like,
all right,
you're really,
yeah,
I've just done some on the way they looked,
that guy.
We're all healing.
Um,
I mean we really are all healing each other,
but um,
I think there's something to doing difficult tasks that it makes life easier.
I really believe that.
I think it makes life more enjoyable.
I think it makes the bright colors brighter and it makes the,
the dull colors,
even them.
Even the,
the,
the bad moments.
If you have real positive experiences with difficult things that you choose to
do on your own,
I think it mitigates most of the hassle of life.
Yes,
I agree with that.
That is,
again,
and I'm not particularly promoting this book because I'd like,
uh,
I'm all right with however things do,
but the point of this mentorship is the idea that someone will exhibit qualities
that you recognize,
you damn fully realized in yourself and that you can sort of model them and
realize them because later you have those qualities.
Like Kevin Hart,
we were talking about how her boy find his positivity.
So real believable on a practical level off he's building his standup.
That guy's fucking diligent and the of when he talked to his,
when he taught for his work schedule,
you quite,
you fetishize hardworking men.
I think I've heard you talk about Dwayne Johnson and Kevin Hart that you liked
the idea of men.
I'm up at those people too.
I mean the Cryo Chamber.
I don't do that though.
I sleep in
a lot of things that they don't do like I,
but I also,
you know,
unlike the rocket lease I do standup mean Kevin does stand up to obviously I
don't know if he does it as much or as often as I do,
but I,
cause I do the clubs.
I have a philosophy about what's required to develop great standup that you have
to do a lot of sets,
you have to do a lot of numbers,
a lot of different places,
different environments and I found that out the hard way through my best
performances in my less good performances,
like what was missing and what did I gain?
You like ACA?
I think Casey has sort of an interesting to bait a know.
I don't know if it's him stand up world at large,
but it's sending,
saying I've thought about a lot is like that.
As soon as I was able to have an audience that would come and see me,
I was like,
I'm out.
Thank you God.
I'm not putting myself through that shit again.
Does Dan hope feels the same way by the way.
And he's one of the best.
He's amazing.
He's absolutely fantastic.
I completely agree.
And like,
cause I thought like,
cause while I feel like is it the comedy club environment warps your material
because you've got a appeal to them and I think you ain't the fucking arbiters
of truth.
You've drunk crazy 2:00 AM motherfuckers like so I guess I perform,
I'll,
what I'll do is I am,
what I'm doing to say at the moment is I'll book the UC be like Oh that places
102 hundred or go Largo or put on events and I'm doing events one,
I mean la cause I think,
oh these people come and they love me and they bring the beads.
He's Vegan cookies and you got to come to the comedy store man.
Go on after Joey Diaz.
Cause I feel like I like a nurturing environment again in mean because I've done
those fucking clubs like you know even comedy store and late night comedy store
in La as well as London.
And I thought,
oh Jesus,
thank God.
And after.
So like I'm interested to you.
That's part of that.
What I think some people could reductively refer to his machismo in you like
that you go,
no,
I'm going in now.
You know what it is.
It's that guy that mounted you and went for the arm bar new escaped.
It's worth it because it was hard.
You're like,
you realize if a child got on top of you and went for an arm bar,
new escape,
you'd feel nothing.
So when you were at Largo performing for children
child stand,
it's like wrestling with a hundred pound women who just started yesterday.
The make a wish foundation,
Russell.
Then tell us your stories.
Thank you.
Thank you children.
But,
but like the counter argument to that is therefore I'm in an environment that is
sympathetic and he is my audience and I'm not biasing I what?
You know,
the idea of it overcoming a greater obstacle.
I completely appreciate you're saying,
but
say you believe in the pure ease of stand up as being some real expression of
yourself as in the Arrow hitting the bullseye.
I feel like I have a vision of what I'm trying to achieve.
An increasingly is becoming about I want my standup,
I want to hang on.
You know,
like as I've always done stories where I feel embarrassed and humiliated,
but I want to hang off it ruminations on what are believed to be the nature of
truth.
And I want people to come out of those things feeling loved,
validate,
excepted and that they're good enough and that they can explore themselves.
It's more of a one man show in a sense is that I don't want to like sacrifice
the laughs,
you know?
I mean I love the loss,
the loss.
Why is where we're at.
You know,
you don't give a sacrifice in a one man show.
I mean,
you can certainly do a one man show that it'd be really funny,
but say you start going into,
yeah,
that's one thing and I'm sort of,
I'm trying to build things like around 12 steps and trying to know and like
doing things that people have some takeaway value from now.
Like,
you know,
like trying to develop that after Joey Diaz in the store.
There's going to be some resistance.
You were of Hannah Gadsby and the controversy of this.
I haven't seen it.
Yeah,
cause what the end of comedy and all that kind of thing.
It's silly.
It's no end of comedy.
But she what she's doing people like and there's nothing wrong,
call it whatever you want.
Sometimes it's funny,
I mean maybe it's standup comedy,
some of my mates and they told me towards the end it could become a sort of
quite aggressive towards yield.
It became like a Ted talk almost.
I guess.
Apparently I'm interested or you know,
that's,
you know,
yeah,
there's enough room for everyone to exist to do whatever they're doing but like
see at the beginning of my guys call it career,
like I used to not prepare at all.
I was still drinking and using.
I got up on stage,
I trop shit up.
I'd get into confrontation.
When I say Trump shop,
I'd take up animals,
shit part animal parts.
I'd got from butchers like like a skull.
We've all meat and stuff and sinew on it.
Chop it up for,
I knew it was released.
Locusts getting to confrontation like so yeah,
exactly.
The reaction you're having is this action they were hacking.
That's,
that sounds,
that frame road I had like a fight.
So I've got scars on my body from bad standup gigs from a time where I've got to
a confrontation.
Like I was making a point about pedophilia saying,
oh,
we're all one cultural mind.
So when a particular paedophile is transgressed against a child,
we're all responsible.
People are like,
what the fuck?
I've got the shit kicked out.
Well that's how I,
you know,
I've still got the scar on my leg that happened at Edinburgh in Scotland.
People didn't take it well,
so,
but what I was trying to do was like create,
I didn't have the skills,
the chops,
the experience than he hoax.
So is so under equipped.
But like what I was trying to do was create environments that felt,
yeah,
I'm much better at doing that now.
I can create kind of an uncertainty in a room or kind of a sense of chaos and
what's happening and then bring it back.
I hope to a humorous conclusion where people feel safe and amused and all of
that kind of stuff.
Now I think it's you can like,
cause I did try and do that and comedy clubs and yeah it was confrontation.
It's not what people want.
So don't you think that by prepping your stand up in those environments that it
biases you towards a type of standup comedy that is limited?
No,
because you can do that other stuff too.
You can always perform to your crowd and you could always expand on things to
your crowd.
But to really put it together without any fluff,
without any nonsense,
without being self indulgent,
with respecting the attention span of the audience that may or may not even be
there to see you most likely is not.
If you go to a comedy club and there's a large,
you know,
if you go to the comedy store any night of the week,
there's 15 plus people on the marquee or on the list.
And the show starts at 8:00 PM or 9:00 PM depending on the night and it goes to
two o'clock in the morning and you know,
you catch waves in there and there's different types of comedy and in that
you're,
you're going to deal with sometimes tired audiences,
sometimes enthusiastic people.
It's all different.
It varies widely.
And I think that um,
in doing that you cut all the nonsense out of your act and you,
you develop an economy of words,
you understand how to captivate people's attention and keep them engaged and to
respect their time,
respect their point of view,
respect that these people have an attention span,
they want to be engaged in,
in the best possible way that you can do it.
And sometimes you develop that through these really difficult sets or you know,
distracted people and drunks and all that stuff.
You can develop that,
those qualities.
You're always going to have your crowd and your crowd.
I mean,
if you have this,
this vision of how you want to put things together,
you could put that kind of thing together at a comedy club.
You're doing it in these 15 minute chunks.
So you just have to figure out a way to grab them and make them really
interested in what you have to say.
You're right.
Because there's obviously in like the comedy store between now as you just
described,
there's a contract,
we're here,
not Gainey at cu.
We're here to laugh every 15 seconds and like,
you know,
comics like,
like Robin Williams or Chappelles,
the,
you know,
the all time greats.
They went,
they go in and accept those conditions.
And I,
you know,
you've seen stuff I'm trying,
like Robin Williams,
he's just like walking around in the crowd in that very room and do,
it's like,
he's like,
he's doing the thing I'm talking about and he's doing it there.
You know,
that's when you think,
yeah,
if,
I suppose I do get that,
that your road testing it to,
uh,
each durability to an incredible degree if you can.
Yeah.
Well think about every time you're saying something when you're,
you have a subject like say if you want to,
do you want to talk about the mentors that you have in life?
There's,
it's an open ended approach.
You have no idea what the correct way to say something is.
You try it,
you,
you write it out,
you say this seems feasible.
Let me try it this way.
And oftentimes people never correct it or they never,
they never adjusted,
they never go back and improve it.
They just say it in a certain way and figure out how to do it.
When you're doing it in front of a crowd,
you're developing these things while also feeling the way people were reacting
to them and feeling their attention span.
And it makes you with proper reflection and truly objective listening to your
material,
it makes you change and shift and adjust things in a,
hopefully in a positive way get in.
And the more you do it,
the more you get a sense of,
maybe this is clunky here and maybe I figured out a better way to say it and I
agree.
But the counter argument could be the,
it could buy us you to a sort of a lowest common denominator area Saber.
That bit where you talk about the sun and you know it's,
you know,
you need it,
he's trying to kill you.
It gives you cancer.
Right.
You know,
like something like what was the journey of that bear standup?
Is this that for me it's like,
oh I think of before I try and make sure there's a tag so I know where I'm going
when I'm out there.
And then it says comparable process to yours,
you're trying your best to get rid of fluff or wherever.
So can you recall like why he's like,
you know,
are you night after night going in with new bits of material,
packaged within things that you were a little more confident?
I put that bit on a special,
I can do it better now.
I know a better way to do it.
And that's part of the problem with doing bits.
So like sometimes you release them on a specialty of a better version of it now.
But my point of that was to a prospective enhancer to let people know that bit
was about like understanding what's happening here.
You are literally floating in infinity and it's almost never discussed.
You're hurling through forever.
There's a fireball on the scar.
It's a million times bigger than earth.
If you stare at it,
you'll go blind.
It's trying to give you cancer.
And if it's not there,
you get sad.
Yeah.
You live in a dream like this is madness.
You're life is madness.
And Yeah it is.
But I wanted,
there's something about that particular way of IX.
See,
cause I figured out a way to express it short in short doses,
in short bursts,
if you know,
if you stare at it and go blind,
it's trying to give you cancer and if it's not there you get sad.
So in that short bursts,
it's,
you know,
like wow.
Yeah.
That is all,
all those things are true.
Like this is crazy.
There really is a fireball floating in the sky and we're just used to it.
We live because of a floating million times bigger than the earth.
Fireball and I,
when you say if you could say something like that and make someone laugh,
you can actually change the way they look at things.
You can actually affect at least the way they look at things.
If we just say something,
sometimes it's profound,
sometimes it registers,
but if you could say something and it forces someone to laugh,
even if they disagree with you,
if they're laughing like,
I don't even fucking agree with this,
but holy shit,
this is funny.
You put that thought deep into someone's head and you allow them to think about
your thought process and and how your creative process and what you're doing to
sort of bring these things out.
Yes.
I like the way you just described the architecture of that.
You've got basically have,
these are some facts about the sun irrefutable now he is how that affects the
way we look at world and exposes
to us that we are just ignorant.
We're not awake to reality.
We can't hold reality in our minds because it's too vast to handle.
I am like,
and I agree with you that let you know what the way of laughter comes access to
kind of deeper truths and I've heard some therapist in fact say that like the
laughter is to shame what grief is to sadness.
That laughter is helping to expel shame and to process Shane.
That is something very important about people coming together and laughing
together.
I like to exist comedically in a world where it's like stars from a deeply
personal perspective and admissions and acknowledgements of humiliation and
shame and vulnerability and travels out to the universal and hopefully archetype
all that you can sort of travel between those points with a comedian.
That thing we both admire Bill Hicks.
Well I think is fascinating is because like,
you know like if you've loved Bill Hicks for a long wild and you discover man
guy works material a lot,
you know like Oh I watched this interview of him on the Australian TV.
He's doing like a bit that I've seen him do,
you know,
in multiple incarnations.
But I have also seen him do interviews,
ways spontaneously talking about gigs.
Terrible gigs have gone badly and he is hilarious.
But it's pretty interesting to me.
And perhaps it's because of that background and that practice of doing clubs
that Hicks is very much a comedian that's,
no,
I'm drilling this fucking thing and I'm staying with,
he was a writer.
I mean he,
he did ad Lib and he did,
he was capable of going on these rants,
spontaneous rants.
But he was a writer,
you know,
he wrote these things out and he was aiming to have an impact with his
commentary.
I mean that was what was he was doing.
It was not just trying to make you laugh,
he was aiming to enhance your,
your perspective on whatever he was talking about.
Yeah.
And as it receives,
very disciplined as a practitioner of it.
Whereas like say a Chappelle,
if it was like he's just got like an hour,
well,
you know,
he's got a very unique process.
Chip Chappelle does.
And he can turn over an hour like no one I've ever seen before.
And I was talking to Darnell wrongs about it recently who was on the Chappelle
show with them and he's like,
we both agreed like he's the best ever at turning over a new hour.
He could have a new one,
he could release a Netflix special and then have a new hour within a couple of
weeks.
It doesn't even make sense.
I don't,
I don't understand how he's doing it.
It must just flat it's,
and he's just,
he's in a great space,
you know,
and he's in a great mindset to do comedy.
You know,
if you pay attention to how,
you know,
when,
when people study,
like if you read outliers and you read how people,
why people are great at what they do and what makes an exceptional.
There's always a variety of factors and whatever the factors are with Dave,
he's got this easygoing personality,
this like very carefully carefree way of looking at things.
He's also gone through a lot of bullshit and his career with the leaving the
Chappelle show and you know,
abandoning million dollars and going to Africa and really understanding what is
real motivation where he was caught up in that world where they were trying to
change him and commercialize his television show.
And he handled it as good as anybody that's ever handled it.
He handled fame and temptation I think better than anyone I've ever heard of.
He just said,
fuck you.
And he just went away.
He went away and then didn't do gigs for years.
People in understand he would show up and do standup places,
but he wouldn't book anything.
So like he wasn't getting paid,
he was just,
he did stand up.
Dave Chappelle did stand up in the park in Seattle.
He brought like a little amplifier and a microphone set up and just started
doing standup and people just gathered round and he did this just to sort of get
him back in touch with his roots.
Cause he used to do a lot of street performing in New York and I saw him do a
street performing in Montreal.
We did a club and then we came out of the club and Dave,
I think Dave was like 18 or 19 is a time just started doing standup on the
street and put his hat out and people would put money in his hat.
I mean,
he was a constantly sharpening that sword and he stopped doing standup for a
long time in terms of like booking gigs.
And then after awhile I said,
fuck it,
I'm going to come back again.
And then he started doing these gigantic gigs.
And then of course he did his two recent,
uh,
Netflix specials where amongst his best work ever.
And you know,
and now he's,
he's working all the time.
He's constantly popping into the comedy store and the comedy cellar and all
these different clubs all across the country and constantly doing standup and no
social media.
He does not,
not involved in any of that stuff.
It doesn't do anything just to just perform,
just does this stuff.
Yeah.
That's interesting.
When you,
it's like I,
I feel that some people found the essence and found their path and live it and
like they,
like they're a Yogi or a priest or something.
He's just got a devotional,
this is who I am.
I'm not doing anything.
It's not that and it,
yeah.
And that's exhibited even in earliest stuff prior to the cry of it.
You know what you would just,
you know,
the crisis if the 50 million walk away thing like by then if he was at I am
doing in clubs,
he was heartened.
He's lucky.
What that what seems so loose on the stage with something that had been refined
as opposed and he's comfortable and he was always good.
He was good when I first met him when he was like 18 I think he was 18 and I was
21 so it was somewhere in that range.
Maybe I was a little older.
Maybe he a maybe it was like how old Dave?
46 47 I think he's five years younger than me.
Is that correct?
46 or 47 45 okay.
So He's more so six years,
six years younger than me.
So you know,
I was probably 25 and he was probably 18 ish,
25,
26,
1817.
But he was,
um,
he was so like calm and like he was very,
like,
it was,
you were attracted to listening to him.
It was like,
like,
look at this guy,
like this guy's like so comfortable in his own skin and so friendly and easy
going and hilarious.
But who he was then and then who he became is all the work that he put in.
You know,
it's like he had this base of this really,
you know,
this curious young,
very wise person who saw things that other people didn't see in the world.
And then he just kept going and just kept going.
And then of course the Chappelle show,
which is in my opinion,
the greatest sketch comedy show of all time,
even though it was only two seasons,
it's the best ever.
And then after that,
I mean he's basically just on standup and done it completely outside of the
system.
He's done some parts in movies and shit like that.
But for the most part,
what he's doing is just stand up completely outside of the Hollywood system.
Completely free.
Just goes up,
you know,
just to talk some shit.
How's a couple of drinks,
laughs and,
and,
and it's incredibly compelling.
He's found his groove,
you know,
and that's,
it's a beautiful thing to watch as a fellow standup comedy practitioner when
someone,
he would treat Cheves this mastery level.
Like we know we were talking about like this Hicks and Gracie of standup comedy
level because that's where he's at right now.
I agree with you.
Become who you are.
Yeah,
he's,
yeah.
He's become himself and he doesn't have things that are getting in the way of
that.
Yeah.
That's what's really interesting.
Like you don't see him,
he's like,
he's not on social media.
He's not on anything.
Twitter or Facebook is not any of that shit.
He doesn't pay attention to any of it.
He's just just being a person,
just being a person and doing stand up,
you know,
it's a,
and he doesn't have to,
which is unique to,
you know,
he doesn't have to promote things.
They just sell out
the adequate.
An amazing example or an amazing example.
I've got promote some things.
Oh what do you got?
Book mentors.
I really learned some powerful lessons there from the story of a,
the apotheosis of comedy that Dave Chappelle's achieved.
Here's these obligations.
Now I'm,
I'm booked here to promote luminary.
My podcast had gone behind a paywall on a platform called luminary.
I'm in a be the Netflix of podcast,
meaning like that,
you know your model will I imagine triumph fervor.
So like from like this week my podcast will be on luminary as part of their
premium content is an APP through which you'll get all podcast.
But my podcast,
it's like you've got to say that the launch now that's lunch cause they tell him
the dice.
Yeah,
I know that was in the process of being created.
Happy with that so far is because he's not launched.
I don't know.
But I,
you know,
you know it like that you're going to leave listeners behind because it's gone
behind a pay wall.
But I spoke to sort of less Sam Harris about a lightweight he,
Sam Harris actually you'd give him,
told me about it.
Yeah.
Right,
right.
And I spoke to like,
and what I recognized is because like the advertising model works here obviously
in your case.
And I thought,
wow,
like there it was like a good deal.
It was a good deal or meant or I can carry on doing podcasts for two for years.
That's
what,
you know what this is and it's support in a lot of other content and essentially
not yielding any creative control of people.
Just if people subscribe,
they get the premium content.
My staff,
how much it was like 105 bucks a month.
Right.
That Trevor Noah,
Lena Dunham,
mine.
How many different podcasts?
I don't know.
I think that when their premium content is like 40 or 50 premium pot,
good luck,
you know,
pieces of content.
Like I said,
for me I thought like,
you know,
it felt like otherwise podcast wouldn't be something that I could continue to do
forever,
every second.
You know,
cause I do films or TV shows or stand up or whatever,
or like a difficult like,
you know,
for me it wasn't a viable thing to pay for,
to pay for people to run it,
to pay for guests to be get to me and all of that kind of stuff.
You know?
No,
no to do,
do ads on your podcasts I did before,
but after it isn't,
it's an ad free model.
There's a benefit to that for sure.
You know,
and a lot of people choose to go ad free and then they use patriarchy or
something like that for her support stuff.
Sam Harris was doing that for a long time,
but then he,
they had an issue with patron about certain censorship of certain individuals
and certain ideological perspectives where they were leaning towards left wing
things and being,
being restrictive towards right wing things.
And then,
you know,
the policing,
the way people behave outside of,
and some people found that objectionable,
so he left and some other people left.
Like Jordan Peterson left.
And I've never entered into patriotic into those waters.
But uh,
I know bird does it.
I think Burt has like one a week that he does it doesn't help were really,
yeah,
he's done is,
he's one of the best.
It's so like,
uh,
like I feel like,
yeah,
I feel like it's an all right thing to do.
But even in,
um,
like just with using things like youtube and social media and you know,
like Spotify or iTunes or whatever,
like,
you know,
as we've seen,
there's a point where there is sort of censorship is a possibility.
Like as you discussed on the Jack,
like at that run of episodes may,
as I said to you by text between the Jack Dorsey,
the reaction to that,
your response to the reaction through Alex Jones and all that tempo.
I thought that was a spate of podcasts.
It's like this is where this medium can be.
The Alex Jones podcast.
I thought it was the godfather of podcasts,
seen the car.
It was put it out tomorrow.
He just gave it to me.
So I put her on what to watch now.
Watch her now.
Yeah.
We have a guy who's hilarious name,
his name is Pauly tune and Paulie tune.
Makes a animated clips for us.
We can broadcast and he's fantastic.
He did one of the Alex Jones.
Eddie Bravo incident.
Yeah.
Well they were there.
No,
not what he's asking him to choke him here I went the flat earth.
this one.
It's so ridiculous.
Here.
We'll play it
for you.
Oh,
I want to hear it.
What's going on?
What's the matter?
Audio cut off.
Okay.
Back it up for the beginning and then it was an exception.
David,
it looks like,
here we go.
The guy does awesome artwork.
Do.
We're going to get you to this next and I I respect you.
Yeah.
Once you guys to yell at each other for three minutes while I go pee.
I gotta pee too.
Okay.
We'll do it and shit.
Shit,
I go first.
Okay.
Anyways,
you are someone that I could talk to about the flat earth conspiracy.
You don't believe in flat earth,
but you can kind of understand where I'm coming from.
If I finance a research ship and make a documentary,
I can't go away for three months.
I will pay one of them.
Which one can you raise?
We're going to need a,
are you guys going to the moon or orbit?
Okay.
You raised the money for a trip.
How raised the money?
Okay,
here's the deal.
Let's Go pee.
Go pee man.
So I'm going to,
we're going to do this Joe Rogan.
Yeah.
No,
no.
We're going to do this job.
You're going to find the edge of the world caps.
Caps.
They're knocking things off.
Film the drop off of my iPhone.
Yes.
Go pee man.
Hopi.
Don't you have to go?
We're going to send someone else.
Alex
[inaudible].
I don't want to be the one to go see in a minute.
Come on high from right now.
I came in here and I proved they're keeping babies alive.
How does it prove that Jamie pulled some shit?
No,
the fuck the governor
really dig people out there campaigning for late term abortions.
You think that Shit's real?
Who would campaign for that day?
So you're telling me it isn't real when I had a fucking Goddamn fucking
conspiracy theory,
you're fucking top of your about to get it
already born.
Babies stop.
Fucking lying.
Don't get best.
No.
You saw the dude is fucking
shut.
It voted their fucking bars.
Hey,
the course.
I believe that we went into a long conversation about her.
We played,
I heard it.
Okay.
You heard it.
I heard the whole podcast talking with it.
Okay.
I don't want to hurt you in mind.
Psychosis is so crazy.
That always thought I was so tough.
He doesn't have to pay anymore.
There's a little bit,
the point is,
is this,
why are we debating whether the earth is flat?
Dude,
they're keeping,
they have human animal hybrids.
Yeah,
that's good stuff.
That's what I mean.
I feel like that is the pinnacle of where this medium can take us.
Watching light cannot say he was in an extreme state.
What about when he kicked out by be comfortable,
keep the belly become priests are listened to that podcast like I go on runs.
I had listened to this and if all fucking hell man,
where else are you going to get this content?
Whereas that agree to it anywhere else.
That's the thing that you'd never get a group of people whose jobs depended upon
keeping the show on the air,
whether they're producers or executives.
They would never agree to that.
They'd be like,
you can't have that crazy fucker on.
You can't have this on,
can have any bravo on all the time.
You think stump world is flat.
Stop this cause you traveling between such a diverse and unusual ideas and,
and sort of the thing we've Alex Jones is as well is that he's like,
he demonstrates to a point that there's veracity in what he's saying.
Some things.
Yeah,
he's right about a lot of things.
You know,
we were just talking about animals,
human hybrids.
We started pulling up these studies where they actually have done studies where
they've tried to create animal human hybrids,
non-viable,
an animal human embryos to trying to grow human organs in different animals.
And there's all sorts of weird scientific shit though.
We're doing,
imagine what they're doing in China behind walls.
Look at this.
China's latest cloned monkey experiment is an ethical mets.
They used CRISPR to add human genes into monkey genes and there's like five
monkeys.
This happened back in January and I don't do it now.
This is a fucking horror movie.
This is a hard way.
This is how the horror movie begins because you think that once,
if that's what's being revealed,
the truth is Darker Das for sure,
for sure.
They're trying to create super soldiers.
Someone is trying to create some super soldier,
some half champ,
half human superintelligent murderous thing that's powered by remote control
pads and not a good objective.
No time to see a good outcome for this superintelligent murderous remote
control.
The only being what if you could send those superintelligent murderers,
chimps to go kill Isis now.
Now we've got a reason to not get them out there.
Now we look,
we've got a nice contract with the this defense contractor and they're going to,
that's how we lubricate the passage to the murderous monkeys is isis.
That's the function of Isis in the cultural conversation is to justify it.
The monkey cell,
which is,
you know what one scared me more than anyone that I've ever read.
Uh,
read about this thing that I'm Darpa was putting together.
So a robot called the eater robot,
ea t our robot.
It's a robot that fuels itself on a biological matter.
So it essentially could eat bodies.
So you've got a murderous robot that eats people
like this fuel was kind of things that human beings could,
it's like people are sat around trying to come up with them.
Well,
they're the,
you know,
they,
they're responsible for a lot of really crazy innovation at times of like
military stuff,
you know,
but Boston dynamics,
they're the ones who make those crazy robots and they work with Darpa,
and those are the ones who make those robots that you can't kick over.
Right.
You know,
I mean,
that's what you need one of those that eats people and you send them to the
battlefield kicking out of,
uh,
no,
that was the first thing we established is you can't kick it over.
I just think that's,
that's the big fear is that future warfare will be our robots versus their
robots.
If we're starting to bring about the worst aspects of the worst things that a
human being can conceive of that channel them through into reality.
It ea does make you fear that the apocalypse is real.
I thought it was bad enough when in the Malays of my younger days,
I see like a four hour.
Wow.
Imagine if there was a cleaning service where the person will come around and
clean,
dressed scantily.
They do that.
They do that wherever devious shit you can dream up.
Someone's trying to turn it back off it and they've taken it to the extent of
the non kick over the robot.
Fleshy in robots.
There's a new one new video today.
Watch this.
This is so scary.
This is Boston dynamics.
Yeah.
There's something very eerie about that type of motion.
You know that the way that the movement of a snake is deeply coded to be
unpleasant.
When you see it the same about you think that movement,
you think that ain't good.
The truck,
it's telling,
wow.
Oh my God,
they're pulling a truck when he's tiny little Tutsis,
those that they're that strong pull a truck.
Fenn little robot,
that's a giant ass truck.
I mean,
he's also just a Husky sled made,
have expensive robots and the truck,
I've spent a lot of time and endeavor to go backwards,
I guess kind of,
but to an angel sent to close.
They're showing how strong these things are and I'm like,
I don't like their gate,
Joe.
That's an unpleasant gate.
Yeah,
you should be on.
You should be uncomfortable with it.
Yeah,
that's not,
I'm not at ease with that
animal and there's no compassion in it.
This is,
it's,
it's feeling lists,
but that's what you got to worry about.
If you've ever seen that episode of black mirror or the lady gets chased down by
the drones,
I have not seen that.
Well,
I've had one way their bees,
no,
there's a woman who's being haunted.
She's being hunted by a robot and it's terrifying because if it's remorseless
lack of humanity and empathy,
it looks just like those things.
Those are real [inaudible] can't.
And that man's go could imagine that he's amazing.
He's amazing.
That show.
It was fantastic.
But these things,
look,
what we have to worry about is once artificial intelligence become sentient and
you can somehow or another attach it to these objects that move and they they
run on solar power or they have you know,
nuclear fuel cells or some crazy shit that allows them to exist for a long
period of time.
Maybe you don't have to worry about
them contaminating environments.
If you plan of killing everybody in the environment and also there's no means of
regulation is there because this,
because this is the apex of human endever there in what,
what can govern that?
What can regulate it and like you say,
there'll be a Chinese equivalent for any of this stuff.
There's nothing that's above it.
Guy.
Now is this a good idea?
Should we pull back?
What did he eat?
Did he just pulled up a things and so they're making that now
they're getting a hundred different models of it are going to be available
starting production in the summer.
It doesn't say how much they're going to wow,
but available for people to buy.
Well,
it says a hundred different models has produce a hundred models.
That probably means it'll produce a hundred of them,
like a hundred different companies are going to want them.
But I bet it's more than that,
if any,
about how much they cost.
It doesn't say how much it's gonna cost.
They're gonna announce that later.
But there's showed uh oh like a robot arm come.
Although it looks so crampy.
Look at that thing.
Imagine we had one of those things in the room filming.
We should get one.
No,
no,
don't take it over.
One day we come here,
he's got red eyes and it's like,
fuck you.
Fuck you.
What?
What did it feel like?
We're the first ones to help it.
The trust be friendly and they listening to us like Alexa.
That's how it begins,
isn't it?
There's something arachnoid an area about that.
It's almost like,
you know,
natural the church.
See if this tunes into the DMT component of what we've been talking about.
It's almost as if we've already experienced to this reality.
We've already been through the version where those evil insectoid robots
takeover.
So when we see on the screen,
oh no,
we're doing that thing with doing that thing where we create those things that
bring about destruction and I believe it's because we've become biased to
commerce and a particular type of progress.
But one narrative has succeeded because we necessarily have to throw off
religion but you know at the dawn of the secular age,
because religion was becoming systems of bias and systems of oppression and what
and systems of a but what do I want to say?
Elevate in certain types of power won't supporting it at least lets go hang on a
minute.
This religion and a lot of it seems like bullshit.
What we've done is we've abandoned the sacred and I think if you abandon the
sacred meaning there is more to life than what we can understand.
I listened to the Brian Cox episode and I've spoke to Brian Cox,
the British physicist,
astrophysicist on my show as well.
And when he talks about,
like you said,
that you know,
we know that there's not some additional component to a human being because we
can break down everything that happens when you move an arm or wherever and I
feel like we only have limited instruments.
We only have limited instruments.
There's certain frequencies that we simply cannot read.
What else is going on when people are having these transcendent psychedelic
experiences,
we're accessing elements of consciousness,
energies and frequencies that we are not able to access while we're in this
state and everything we were achieving and everything we're building,
we're building on this platform and the bias of this platform is towards pri
progress and materialism and I think the result is fleshy in robots and those
evil monkey warriors,
soldiers.
We might want to calm down.
I have a little talk about what it is we're trying to design.
Yeah.
I don't know if I agree with Brian on that particular point that we think we
know everything about where consciousness emanates.
I don't think that's necessarily true,
but I like the fact that he thinks that way because you sit your rigid hard
liner for science and the guy works at cern.
I mean,
he's a brilliant,
brilliant man.
So of course he thinks that way.
I also don't think he's ever had a DMT experience.
That's right.
I wonder that.
Yeah,
they say some people I think give him a quick dose.
You know,
because I as well,
I respect Brian and he's perfect in my point.
Similar to the hunt in argument,
I can,
you know,
I happen to believe in God,
but like I,
when I talked to Brian Cox,
I got to the point where I was saying,
all right,
even though I believe in God and you are an atheist,
so though he said,
I don't call myself an atheist.
Well I felt like we both got to the point where we said compassion,
kindness and love are the most important thing.
So in a way,
who cares?
So when you sit there,
when you see you believe in God,
do you believe in the traditional God of Christianity?
What do you do?
You believe in God as a concept?
Do you have your own definition for it?
That I believe that that state of oneness and transcendence that you're talking
about when you feel your DMT experiences but says,
you know,
love and kindness and love and awareness,
I believe that is the most real thing.
I think that proceeded all matter.
And I think that we,
that we can interact with it.
So I don't believe that God in a sort of ingest a guy away,
that the whole world is like an interactive by biological living,
breathing God s I believe that we,
I believe yes,
that and that we can commune with it.
And I am.
Furthermore,
the relevance of it for me is that it suggests to me that we should be acting
kindly and lovingly.
And when we're thinking about how do we organize our systems,
that our awareness of that energy accessible to all of us should be paramount in
our understanding of how we organize.
So like what I think is like that we should look at,
you know,
like we've been through as human beings in so many advents that agriculture
technology industry thinking that we were the,
the,
you know,
the sun went around their thinking that the earth was flat with all due respect
to Eddie Bravo,
you know,
and we,
and before each of these realizations and each of these changes,
we always think we are at the summit.
We never know what's going to be the thing that's going to change.
My suspicion is that what's going to change is out of the way we relate to
consciousness and the way we see ourselves as individuals that we start having
an understanding that what the,
that becomes a priority.
That thing you've described.
If like when I've come back from DMT trips,
I recognize this is just an illusion and it's not real.
I think that will like,
I believe that we need to prioritize that and progressing along that line.
What are the implications of this not being the most real frequency there is?
How do we organize society on that basis?
How does that affect how we relate to one another?
What kind of,
how should we be governing?
How,
how does that affect justice?
That that should be in the mix instead of our many fucking arachnoid weird gait
robot,
motherfuckers can we cook on?
That's the way we're going,
the progressive technological route,
because it's created medicine because it saves so many lives because it's given
us wonderful technology,
the spirit of entrepreneurialship,
but all of that energy,
it all gets pushed in one direction.
They're all goes that way and I feel that we need to invite that back.
The sacred and the divine need to be back in the conversation.
Well,
there's certainly going to be pros and cons with everything.
You know,
there's definitely pros and cons with the creation of technology.
I think of this,
I think of human beings as if you go back to single celled organisms,
they have very little awareness of their environment and then as it became
primitive bugs,
you know,
as as as things evolved,
they develop more awareness.
But even us in comparison to certain animals,
certain now animals have heightened senses of smell and survival instincts.
But they're also colorblind,
you know,
and they,
they don't see things.
They see edge detection like this.
One of the things about deer,
they see movement.
So like if you were a camouflage and you know your,
your pattern is broken up with a grid and then you stay put,
they don't see you.
Yeah,
they just did.
It doesn't mean it doesn't register to them.
They see movement.
So we have a far more complex system of recognition than they do in terms of
like visually the way we see things.
And I think that whatever skills or whatever senses that we've evolved,
I don't think that's it.
I don't think we've reached the pinnacle of it.
And I think that as beings become more and more evolved,
they'll probably gain more and more senses.
And that could be directly related to technology.
It's totally possible that what's going on with technologies that we're also
developing through external means a way for us to see the world,
a way for us to view what they've done with the large Hadron collider is like
the best example of it,
right?
What they do with the Hubble Space Telescope.
And other telescopes,
you're,
you're using technology to gain awareness and to see more things.
And that this is the good side of technology is that it's allowing us to have a
far greater understanding of all the variables that surround us that we might
not be able to detect with our senses.
That this is a part of who we are.
And then I think when you're talking about things like psychedelic experiences,
that's probably another realm of understanding that we haven't really achieved
yet because we're,
we're still evolving as,
as a,
as a species,
as a thing.
What I think is interesting is that the continual bias along that technological
path is towards profit.
You know,
when we see those machines,
the end point is always how do we make,
how do we maximize profit?
There is no like the influence of how do we do what's right.
That's like a sort of a,
a person,
like a sort of a general ethical,
uh,
what do I want to say?
Sort of is not being introduced.
There is no regulation like,
uh,
you know,
look out on that.
You know,
ultimately people will create the warrior monkeys or the most profitable
machines people because they're,
the counter argument isn't being made.
No one is like what I'm saying,
no one's making it there.
There's just,
there's no union of uh,
you know,
there's no sort of clear opinion of,
hang on a minute,
where could we be going?
No,
there is no body or ideology that's able to oppose the relentless march of
capitalism.
I'm not sort of like a flower or capitalism is bad.
Here I am promoting a book using or an iPhone or you know what I mean?
Um,
we're all swimming in it,
right?
But what I'm saying is that if we acknowledge there are transcendent realms,
there is information and data that exists beyond what we're able to receive with
our senses.
How are we going to incorporate that in the way we organize?
Cause otherwise this off the magnetism,
the Pole,
the g force of water most profitable,
what's going to continue to suit the requirements of the powerful that will
always,
the bias will always fall in that direction.
And it seems like where that's heading is certain kinds of ecological disaster,
certain kinds of economic inequality,
certain kinds of conflict,
you know,
and like we're not,
one of them are the simple uh,
uh,
experiments that I apply is,
you know,
if we,
if when people say,
oh,
what's wrong with the world world's I fucked all this polarity,
I sometimes think,
well,
who is benefiting from how it is now?
Are there,
is anyone benefiting?
Are there any groups,
institutions or individuals for whom this current state is beneficial?
And if the answer to that question is yes,
then look at who those institutions are and they are most likely to a degree
involved in establishing and maintaining these systems.
And there are,
you know,
is the tuitions and individuals and organizations that this works just fine for,
but are they just capitalizing on it or are they organizing it and is a normal
part of the way human beings operate with this constant desire for innovation,
constant desire for improvement.
We always want to push further.
No,
no one's comfortable where they are.
They will always want to be in a better place.
And this is almost like it's built into capitalism,
right?
I agree that this materialism,
which is built into capitalism also is what fuels innovation.
Yeah,
because you want the newest iPhone so they have to design it and build it and
make it all right and when new things come out,
like this new robot that apparently you're going to a hundred models,
whatever that means.
What that is is this is is they're going to sell it so there's like it's fueling
innovation.
Someone else would come along,
compete with Boston dynamics and then there'll be,
there'll be innovation wars.
If these innovation wars weren't in place right now,
our phones would look nothing like the iPhone 10 it just wouldn't,
it wouldn't look like the Esx,
it would look like when those was,
it would look like,
but there would be no,
no incentive for them to compete against all these Samsung devices and Huawei
devices and all that stuff is fueling this innovation,
but it's all being fueled by capitalism.
You're quite right that that,
that innovation is one of the benefits of the maintaining this system.
But it seems to me that we are excluding other factors like that,
that,
that recur throughout human cultures.
We all have an idea of fairness of justice and yeah,
I don't want some clunky,
weird sort of eastern bloc phone made out of gray plastic only one button on it.
But like we have to I suppose,
examine as a society and as individuals what is important to us where I think,
you know,
we've talked touched several times upon the fact that as an individual you're
more likely to bias yourself towards negative information online.
You know,
like we do have a degree of individual power and individual responsibility and I
feel like if enough people awaken to the possibility of different narratives
that,
that the capitalist idea of innovation and success and progress that,
that all of these words can be examined.
What do you mean progress?
That assumes a teleology,
a purpose,
a destination.
If all time is happening at once.
If space is infinite,
like you know that bit of yours of liking it to try and fathom for a moment the
limitlessness that were existing within,
then all these things are constructs.
This is a construct and it is good to have technology,
but it's possible to like at points times of crisis such as what it feels like
we're at now.
Now though that people have said,
well,
we always feel that every generation thinks that they're the one because they
know their own impending death is coming and they narrativize that into
something social and global regardless.
There's got to be a time where we start to introduce different ideas into our
systems.
It seems like there's room for that now because we do live in a toe,
a truly global culture that there is the possibility for monoliths to introduce
new innovation and there is nothing that can oppose it or regulate it.
We're starting to see this kind of breakdown.
So I'm interested in how we can individually prepare ourselves to organize
society differently.
To be able to overcome pretty superficial differences.
Like,
Oh,
you go hunting and I don't go hunt in,
we,
I really gives a fuck.
They start talking about how we can organize the size where people who go on in,
it'll don't go hunting,
can live peacefully in different ways,
not entirely governed by a small cabal.
You know?
And and I'm sure plat power is more complex and that that seemed to be hugely
biasing the direction of this.
So called pro.
I think you answered your own previous questions when you're talking about
whether or not you can be spiritual and funny and like what are you doing?
Can you carve that path out for yourself?
That what you're doing there by explaining that would influence people,
would give people a perspective that allows them to say,
yeah,
like why are we doing this and what is the purpose of this?
And if enough people hear those words and have that perspective introduced to
them,
it'll change the way they interact with the world.
And that changes the world.
It really does.
And that's one of the more powerful things about discussions.
When someone like you says something like that and it resonates with people and
they start thinking like,
why am I living this?
Like what
if I'm only have,
if I really do only have 50 years to live,
why am I living these 50 years in some really unproductive bullshit way that's
not satisfying at all?
Cause I just want a bigger house.
Like what is it?
Do I want a faster car?
Do I want to have expensive piece of jewelry?
Like what is,
what is the purpose of this path that I'm on now versus a path that I could be
on?
And what is the real conflict that we all experienced between each other?
Is it,
how much of it is due to a lack of communication?
How much of is due to a lack of real listening and understanding?
And one of the things I've said about like comments and podcasts and stuff like
that,
I think one of the reasons why a lot of people get mad,
and I've tried to think this through,
like why some people,
some of the responses so negative to things that don't it seem innocuous on the
outside.
I think it's because it's frustrating when you don't have a say.
Yeah,
give to people like see you and I are talking about something.
It's probably some guy right now going,
what jobs fucking stop with all your spiritual bullshit.
Here's what you do.
You'll wake up when you're fucking alarm clock goes off.
You never hit snooze.
You get out the door,
you put your hours in.
Eventually you get better.
You take care of your family,
you act like a fucking man.
And there's probably people like that,
that they're upset that they feel like we're pontificating too much.
And this is all just,
you know,
just mental masturbation the ways it is.
But that's part of how you'd solve these things and think these things through.
I believe they deserve their say.
Yeah.
Well,
and that's one of the things that,
you know,
I've been a person that goes to sort of 12 step support groups is you recognize
that everyone's individual experience is valuable.
It's not like that.
And I've got over the idea that there's some external thing can be imposed and
like,
you know,
whilst there are many people that are,
we could say not using their 50 years to maximum effect because there are,
you know,
pursuing odd material goals.
There are many,
many more people that have never been introduced to the idea of freedom because
from the moment they're born,
they're economically tyrannized and told that your only,
if you are not economically valuable to their system,
you are not valuable at all.
And that isn't,
that's only an idea.
But you know,
if you don't,
if you can't become a lawyer or you know,
a comedian or whatever,
fuck you.
Well so many of us are trapped in the expectations and values of our parents
too.
That's a real problem with people.
Don't let their children become an individual.
You know,
they force their children to follow their own rigid ideology.
They shame them when they don't.
I agree with that,
but do you not imagine that a dick fair degree of that stuff is unconscious?
Do you,
don't get to you and I agree for sure.
Probably unconsciously imposing things on our kids.
100% but not with guilt and women.
If your kid comes to you and say,
Dad,
I didn't know.
I know you wanted me to be a doctor,
but fucking I want to play bongos.
I just want to be the best Bongo player of all time.
I bet you'd probably be like,
Hey,
learn the fucking pause.
Give me a hug and I'll go get those bongos come the best damn band.
Goa.
You can dare.
Or even mediocre.
Sure,
but there are fathers out there.
I'd be like,
the fuck you are.
You're going to be a goddamn doctor.
Stop being a pussy and you're going to go back to medical school and you got to
pick up,
your studies are going to get you a tutor and you're going to perform because
we're all Wilson,
Wilson and Wilson family's been physicians,
so it's 1820 your brand time immemorial.
If the Wilson's have been positioned,
he made people buy down on a leather strap before amnesia.
They sought off legs and he kept those people alive.
You want to play Bongos?
You little fuck yeah,
people get mad.
But my bias is towards my kid,
like,
uh,
like sort of like when we was back in England,
like I was aware of like grandparents or whatever,
reacting a spiders and stuff going,
oh,
spiders is scary.
I'm a dumb fucking teach them that spiders are scary.
I don't want her to think of things is scary.
Tell it that this spot is a call there.
All right.
There's nothing,
you know,
like you say and you're aware of familial influence like that.
They wanted the hair to be a certain way.
They want them to wear certain things they want them to like,
yeah.
Part of the veganism is like,
if you make these kids Vegan,
at least now I know wherever they go,
there's gonna be so many restrictions on their food.
I've not made the kids Vegan like where the hell they want.
It's up to them.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Where's my goats.
Dot.
Where's my ticker tape parade.
But like,
so,
but like,
you know,
I don't know what car,
we don't know our own biases.
We don't know what,
where we've been institutionalized,
you know,
cause how,
the very nature of their unconscious is we are not aware of it,
you know?
So I suppose in a sense a cook,
it continued open mindedness and willingness to change must be part of any
dialogue to go into the seat driving general.
I might not actually know what's,
that's why I'm not,
when I was 20,
if you were to sit about the hunt in,
I'd be like,
oh no man,
no.
I'm like,
yeah,
Jesus,
there's so many ways of seeing the world.
There's so many ways of looking at what's natural and what's correct.
Um,
you know,
what do I know?
Hunting,
hunting is like many things in that.
There's no real clean answer.
There's no yes or no good or bad because you could think there is.
But then you find circumstances like wild pigs or invasive species.
Like I go hunting on a place called the knights and one of the small islands of
Hawaii.
Mm.
There's somewhere in the neighborhood of 3000 people and 20,000 deer.
It is so overpopulated with deer and they have to kill them.
They killed them every day.
They hire snipers.
They hire people to get on.
People were slamming and with their cars.
I mean,
they are fucking everywhere.
And their access deer,
they're not even from there.
They're from,
uh,
someone brought them over from India to give to King Kamehameha and like the 18
hundreds there.
Their animals actually that evolve to get away from tigers.
So there's this insanely fast,
beautiful deer that are everywhere.
They're forced to kill.
Well,
the good news is the people that are a low income people,
the island always have meat.
There's,
there's meet everywhere.
Everyone can haunt.
It's really easy to find them.
You can,
you could find them and if you,
you know,
if you want,
you can go kill him.
Yeah,
I've got no moral
judgment about that.
You know,
if there's rats in my house,
what,
I'm not going to put down poison.
I'm going to go.
Oh,
but that's the thing,
right?
We're allowed to flourish.
You should probably feel bad about killing a rat.
Right?
As a Vegan.
I do feel bad spot.
I'm hungry.
What about like,
I wouldn't,
I wouldn't swap a mosquito.
Even the Dalai Lama,
even the Dalai Lama low.
I see him.
He went like the first time a gentle brush.
The second time,
a harder one for time.
Smack the data.
Like the Dalai Lama gives them free chances.
Then you're out.
You might be reincarnated as saint back.
Can I go for a tea please?
Yeah,
sure,
sure.
Go ahead man.
It's almost three o'clock already if you believe it or not.
Fresh in my bladder was under.
He's such a character.
His neat,
he's got these incredibly long rants,
you know,
but he's so I'm self aware and introspective is always analyzing himself.
Trying to find if he's doing right,
I get a kick of these celebrity dude's doing Jujitsu too.
I think it's hilarious.
It's awesome.
It's cool.
It's cool to hear him talk about it.
You could tell,
you know,
the struggles with it.
I just saw someone else said they just started it and I can't remember who it
was.
Someone famous.
Yeah.
Might not be relevant at all,
but I'm trying to think.
Demi Lovato is like a purple belt or some shit.
She's been doing it for a long time.
Uh,
Russell,
who I've trained with it Russell's a legit blue belt.
I rolled with Russell and I was like,
wow.
Russell really knows Jujitsu.
He's actually doing the right stuff here.
It's hard.
It's hard for someone to go from a place of where a guy like Russell brand is
handsome,
beautiful,
famous man who is got some strange plumber sitting on his face.
He ain't going on his arm.
And his description of it is awesome.
Yeah.
It feels with bow feces in his bowels and yeah,
that veganism stuffs for the birds though.
Sorry.
Vegan people to eat eggs.
If you don't want to kill any animals,
please just find,
find a good farm that has pasture raised eggs and see how much better you feel
or eat animals that are assholes.
Find animals that are assholes in the woods.
Only at the assholes.
Somebody sent me this horrible video that I've seen many times before of a a
bear,
uh,
killing a deer in the backyard and the deer screaming the barest,
tearing it apart.
I'm sure you've seen that before,
right?
And uh,
he sent it to me and he goes,
okay,
now I get it.
Like I didn't think,
I thought like if a bear got a deer,
that it would be just,
oh,
hey,
this is just how nature works.
Like,
no,
this is horrific violent act of this animal tearing this other animal apart.
Now,
would you prefer that than a hunter?
Because 99 times out of a hundred,
when a hunter kills an animal,
it's way quicker there.
That's the video.
It's horrible.
It's a horrible video.
This animal,
I think it's actually a black bear.
I think it's either a grizzly or a color phase black bear.
But it takes a long time too.
If you,
if you haven't seen the video,
it's a long one.
And the animal makes them horrible noises.
We're talking about a Russell returns.
We're talking about a video that I've seen before about this bear that kills
this deer in this guy's yard and the guy films in the years making these
horrible noises and uh,
this guy sent,
sent it to me and he goes,
now I get it.
He goes like,
get with the wild is actually all about because you don't really see it that
much.
You don't really,
it's very rare the actually seeing an animal kill an animal.
So we have these romantic dignified ideas of what the food chain looks like out
there.
Yeah.
Nature is brutal.
I mean I don't try and impose on my dog the kind of conditions that would help
my shelf too.
You should have an organic garden if you really want to do it right.
Because if you're getting into large scale agriculture,
you're buying food from people that grow it.
They're running over fucking rabbits and mice and killing things with pesticides
and there's no,
there's no removing yourself from death,
but just by eating vegetables,
it's just you don't,
they have to re also they have to like when with large scale agriculture there,
that ground,
all those animals get displaced,
fucks the whole ecosystem up,
whatever area they're planting on,
and then when they roll over it with those gigantic combines and pull up that
grain,
they're chewing up everything.
That's why vultures always circle where combines are.
As soon as they have fresh cut,
the vulture starts showing up because they know there's going to be something
that got jacked.
Did she know that that mono culture is unhealthy?
They're only resistance to [inaudible] like permaculture and healthier.
Better agricultural models is commerce and profit.
That's okay.
No,
no,
no.
You communes which you could have as a community gardens.
Yes,
yes you could,
but the only way,
but if you start,
if we start saying,
hey,
why don't we not have mono culture anymore because it's unfair and it's
unreasonable,
reasonable,
they go,
we can't because a,
it's profitable to have it and people won't bow forward food.
But all of that is like it,
you know,
a city,
an interrelated system that's sort of grid locked into protecting itself.
You know,
like there's this spiritual Maxime wisdom is acting on knowledge and that is not
the world we live in.
We know things and then we just ignore it,
you know,
like,
or as individuals or as or as you know,
corporations and as groups and like what I feel like I'm trying to do as an
individual is hold myself to that standard.
Like I know that's not good for me to do that anymore.
I'm not going to do that.
I'm going to do like,
oh,
I'm going to watch myself and I'm going to watch that behavior and I'm going to
try and improve.
You know,
like I don't want to go.
Like when my first impulse and heading down to the day he Biro Jujitsu places,
I feel nervous and I'm feel confident doing it.
I don't want to go or whether it's like giving up meat or whatever,
but I'm doing these things.
In a sense,
those,
I think these are the kinds of improvements I can make now.
Like when we almost don't expect that of politics anymore.
You don't expect a sort of a political figure to say,
well look,
listen,
monoculture is having a terrible impact.
They'll make some gestural thing,
wouldn't they?
They'd go,
look,
we're going to try and control Facebook and Google a little bit and we're going
to try and reduce emissions this amount.
Now we'll go,
listen,
we know that's wrong.
We're not to do that anymore because there's too many powerful interests.
That's why I was susceptible to the Vegan documentary.
You know?
Of course there's the ethical reasons in my opinion for becoming Vegan,
but because it's like the reason that these kinds of foods are promoted is
because these powerful groups lobby government and lobby the group,
the organizations that set the standards until they shut up and comply.
You could sort of say that about vegetable based foods to power league and
obviously some sea
vegetables,
just corn just growing,
right?
If definitely monoculture
as the same.
That is the same.
You know like you're saying that the reason that is continuing is because it's
profitable and that,
but these ideas aren't going to get explored because we are on one path,
one teleological journey.
Like that's sometimes what I feel like when people talk about the frets of
different cultural influence,
Eg Islam for example.
Right.
I feel like,
well we already live in a kind of fundamentalism that's invisible to us because
it's all,
we know we live in a culture that if something isn't profitable it will not
survive and I don't think that's how human beings are set up to exist.
I have this rather lovely anecdote about like I was coming back from a Gig and
it was a woman like she,
her car broke down the side of the road.
I had a driver,
forgive me,
I'm not poor anymore.
Forgive me.
I had a drive and we see this woman,
she's back.
The car side of the road of cars broke down and different light.
It's a nighttime and let few different people stop and help are the first guy is
like aces in England.
It's like a Polish immigrant guy comes and helps you know my driver's Muslim
gazer he's helping.
I'm trying to help.
Pretty inefficient.
Mersay cause you know like if you're a famous person,
when you go into a situation there's sometimes you don't want to be recognized.
Is that the time just kind of good to be recognized when you're not recognized
at all?
I always think,
oh I'm not being a or recognized in this attrition.
No one recognized me in that time.
So I've just a weird Giza or the side of the road trying to help someone who had
a minor accident without any relevant skills.
Then someone stopped with relevant skills.
He was like a paramedic.
He took control of the situation.
He was ordering people around you stand here,
you do this.
Go and get that.
Go and get my head torch.
He said at one point he had a fucking head torch.
This guy serious and like he like,
he brilliantly resolved the situation.
Um,
you mean like a light?
He had a head torch.
Torch.
Like a light.
I'm sorry.
Is He Bernie's and welding?
How's it doing?
He all right.
Fair enough.
Yeah.
This seems a little bit here.
I just wanted to clarify.
I'm
not kind of strange people.
The way you spelled tires.
Like what's that?
Why doing in there that's necessary.
Thanks for Queen.
Is Color have a u in it.
You can eat that you to round off the second syllable of color.
You savage,
young brutes with your color.
Color.
Color,
sneaker sneaker.
We can't even pronounce a sport that we do.
I mean it's a,
it's a Burnham catastrophe.
The way to burn him.
Bernie,
I know.
Burning Ha.
Birmingham,
this,
and this guy had what you would evidently call a headlight or even that doesn't
sound right beside the lamp headlamp and the old thing to have in your vehicle.
No,
no,
no.
I have one headlamp in your car.
Well,
you anticipate in,
if you get stuck somewhere,
man,
anything happens.
You should have a headlamp.
This is the kind of person that you want pulling over.
Well,
listen,
when you go hunting,
one of the things that happens is you're in the woods and when that happens,
when the sun goes down,
you can't see where the fuck you're going.
You have to have a headlamp.
How every hunter very far.
I've a really good one.
A really good one.
So lighting stuff up,
isn't that going to alert the Oh,
you're,
you're no hunt at night,
right?
It was illegal.
Once the sun goes down,
there's no hunting.
You have to be able to see what you're shooting.
You shoot a person,
so you have these funds,
him sorts of rules,
lights on your head or just to help you navigate through the woods and to spot
predators.
Because of course if you're vulnerable,
you know,
and you see giant eyes ahead that are nine feet off the ground,
you're like,
oh fuck,
it's a bear.
She wakes,
retreat,
come in.
It's like hold on.
The hunters that happens.
I've had experiences where I've run into predators in the wild.
Uh,
particularly,
uh,
one time in Canada I ran into a grizzly bear and uh,
looking in the eyes and it wasn't even a big one.
It was like a six foot bear.
Wasn't huge,
but it looks right through you.
It looks right to you.
And so when you run into an animal that's killing shit every day and it looks at
you,
there's like a demonic look at its eyes.
I've mean,
I've seen black bears before.
You don't see that look of a grizzly bear,
which is,
you know,
more predatory.
They have a crazy look in her eyes.
It's really interesting.
I made eye contact with a couple of predators,
a shock once in a shark cage on like when I was doing that film,
Sarah Marshall,
that 10 years ago,
well when in a shark cage and right and lay lower you down and you see a shape,
a shot come towards you.
It's like it's swimming through time.
It's like,
it's come from every area.
It looks at you.
We'd like you think,
oh Whoa,
fuck,
you know,
unlike,
and I was terrified in that cage and lighten that Ed Norton,
which there and with the Allison,
they were on the island as well.
They were mates for people that were in the movie.
They go in the water outside of the cage.
Other,
other fucking mind that seems sign,
isn't it?
This shock was little and apparently is not a kind of shot each.
She,
but even the eye contact and then,
and it's fucking teeth.
I don't even look at it.
And then another thing I looked at once I was in a tiger sanctuary in India
and I like,
uh,
I didn't let the vehicle while I was in,
Oh,
this is a,
I should,
I should have made clear that I should I say uncomfortable.
There's a bad cheap over there.
So I've got out of it to transition and my mate goes,
or you want to get in the car now my is a fucking tiger over there.
And it was a tiger like only 10 foot away.
Maybe I'm exaggerating.
Hold up 20 foot maximum.
Like if it was near and the way that that thing looks,
I mean cause it's so beautiful as well.
The intensity of being looked at by that fucking creature have some powerful
shit.
You don't want eye contact with her.
I don't want to look at something that's got like that.
You can't negotiate with the ICAN.
I feel that he'd look at me even with the Jujitsu,
like I've got that little moment where I go,
hey,
come on this Elle Russ.
Yeah,
we have a tie.
Go.
She doesn't care about your mortgage.
Yeah.
Neither does that.
Grizzly bear doesn't care.
They'd look through your kids.
Yeah.
They don't care.
No,
but that's all it's doing all day long.
Unbelievable.
Cause that's as true as everything we reflect on it.
Just to ask,
who gives a shit about your theories?
I don't
know what that is.
So their idea of what the wild is is really based on two things.
One,
their their actual love of animals.
They know,
right?
It's like dogs and cats.
So the animals that we know we,
we,
we have this connection with them.
So we think that these are animals.
There's science projects,
man.
Those are not animals.
Real animals don't give a fuck about you.
They,
they,
they either indifferent to you or they're scared of you or they want to eat you.
That's real animals.
The relationship that you have with a dog.
It's like a child.
Like my dog is more like a child to me than he is like an animal.
I mean he's like my little friend that doesn't get to speak.
He doesn't talk.
But you know,
an animal in the wild is a competing organism.
They're competing amongst all the various organisms in whatever ecosystem
they're in.
And either they're at the top or if they're there or somewhere below that.
And that's just how it goes in every deer has looking around cause there's cats
and the cats are slowly sneaking up on them every fucking day of the week.
And if you go in a place where there's deer,
you best believe there's going to be mountain lions there.
Cause that's how it operates.
And when you see that in the Wa,
it's so rare.
It's so rare to be around that.
But when you see that in the wild,
then you get a deeper understanding of what it means to be an animal.
What's horrific is factory farming.
What's perverse and disgusting as the way animals are treated when these lives,
these livestock companies pump these animals and these warehouses and make them
stand in their own shit all day and then abused them and the horrific nature in
which their race.
Yeah,
all that should be illegal ag gag laws.
Those laws were whistle blowers get arrested.
Those should be illegal.
Those are immoral.
They're letting people know what goes into your food and those people are being
punished for that.
All that shit is crazy.
They're being punished because it hurts business.
Yes.
Well it should fucking hurt business.
You're doing something that we all think is a moral,
that's how I feel about it.
I don't think there's anything wrong with,
even if they,
if,
if there should be standards and how cows are raised,
how chickens are raised,
let them live like actual counts.
That's beautiful and there's a way that they can do that where people like Chris
Pratt.
Yeah,
from Guardian's got great guy.
He has,
he raises sheep and he eats them and he even gives them out to people.
He has butchers that take care of it,
these sheep or treated like,
like they're loved.
They're not scared of people and then literally they get walked into this room.
They have no idea what's going to happen.
A bolt gets put on the top of their head,
Bang and the lights go out.
Now you could say that should never happen and those sheep should just live
forever.
Okay.
You could,
I could understand that argument.
Or You could say,
boy,
if you're going to eat meat and you're going to eat the meat of an animal,
that you know how it lived and there was no horrific moments in its life.
It just one day the lights went out.
That seems like the best,
most ethical way to do it.
Maybe even perhaps more ethical than hunting.
Yes,
because when I'm hunting an animal,
um,
it's,
you know,
it's out there in,
this is crazy state where it's always looking to get eaten.
These sheep have no idea that can be eaten.
They think that everybody's there,
buddy,
and then one day they die.
Yeah,
man,
I agree with that.
You know,
like yeah,
there's,
it's difficult to bring ethics to that.
That's clearly in my view,
a matter of opinion.
Some people think that's okay.
Say the,
they could turn it around on me and say,
you could do that same like thought experience with people.
Like,
why don't you just see people like,
hey,
the personal lived a perfect life.
You put a bolt in the top of their head and bang,
shut the lights out and then they turn into barbecue.
Look at,
yeah,
that's a very pronounced and vivid way.
But I would say that in a sense we're all like we're being commodified,
imprisoned in clothes.
He made like the very fact that a law has been made to prevent people regulate
in or revealing the truth around that,
revealing it,
showing shows where the true bias of this system is in a way.
I think that one of the cultural jobs this podcast has performed,
and this is like whether deliberately or not is it demonstrates that the old
political lines that we used to comfortably abide within a star into sort of
break down cause you know like something like an obvious signifier of a
particular type of person.
I he,
I go hunting now we have to accept is coupled with your view that the
agricultural industry needs to be regulated and it's disgusting.
Now there,
you know,
they're,
we have complete and total agreement and we both can see that the way that
legislation is set up is biased towards corporate interest,
commercial interest and profit.
Yeah.
And so for me,
bloody whether or not,
you know,
Chris,
pat prive your own sheep I finger,
no problem man.
Woe what last night.
I don't need to spend my time worrying about that.
I'm a little bit like Alex Jones,
like with the,
why are we worrying about flat earth if they've got them babies and all of that
stuff besides like why we focus on the things
that are making a genuine difference to the way people are living lives.
Yeah.
And it seems to me that the one of the priorities is in a new global landscape
that we're living with.
What are the dominant forces and what are the goals of the dominant forces and
how detached at those goals from the lives of what you might say are ordinary
people,
the majority of people to use it less complex term.
And what's probably most horrific about reforming the system is that the people
that are going to suffer the most are the people that are the poorest.
So if you think of like a fast food in particular,
right?
There's a lot of like really poor people that rely on fast food because it's
very inexpensive.
If you go and you can get a lot of calories for a small amount of money,
right?
But if you go from the fast food restaurant and then you go down the line to
factory farming and then somehow know that they eliminate factory farming and
they say,
no,
no.
If you're going to raise animals,
you have to have the same sort of standards that we would expect if we knew you
if we were there.
We want pastures,
we want animals living in the wild.
We want,
I mean,
you know,
fenced in,
but like living like an an actual animal,
not this crazy warehouse bullshit.
You guys are running well,
that's going to up our operation costs.
Well then that's how it's going to be.
So then the beef becomes far more expensive.
Now the beef becomes far more expensive than what a fast food.
What are the restaurants do?
Well,
they're going to have to make things more expensive too.
So who's gonna suffer the poor people who's going to suffer with cheap meat and
supermarkets,
poor people that can't afford it now.
But I think that what happens,
Jvs,
you stopped to pee,
you have started to pull a Fred that reveals how the fabric of our culture is
corrupted because it shouldn't be more expensive.
The only reason it's more expensive is because everything is put into a capital
based ideology.
We're already,
I've heard many times on this show you discuss in universal basic income.
This is that the beginning of looking at alternative economic models and there's
an argument for saying everyone has the right to a nutritious diet.
Everyone has the right to a safe home.
You know?
So like if we start prioritizing those ideas above these organizations have the
right to maximize profit,
we were like,
we're homeless,
that they're maximizing profit that's getting taken off the table.
And then there comes your counterargument about innovation.
Well,
I would say if innovation slows no problem because we are,
we've decided as a culture to prioritize housing and nutrition for the majority
of people.
Now you can start say that starts to,
you know,
that's,
that's kind of socialism but,
and I don't think that that can work on a,
on a continental scale.
I think you have to,
we have to break down centralized systems,
whether those are corporate centralized systems or national.
I feel that the time has gone where there's too much diversity,
but like they're not too,
they're probably always was diversity.
People at different,
we're influenced by our culture is our schools,
our education,
our class,
our race.
There's all these factors.
And then to expect us all to live in this sort of single bandwidth of this is
what America is,
or this is what France or this is what England is,
people at these two different now.
But
what if it does?
It seems like the standards we were adhering to unconsciously or otherwise,
he's,
these groups have the right to make as much money as they can and to interfere
with that is UNAMERICAN or on British or wherever it was,
you know,
beyond national ideas.
I'm sure.
So,
you know,
for me that's the way you pull that Fred.
Oh,
it's the poor that will suffer within.
No,
we have to rule out the poor suffer.
So we had,
so what happens in the end,
you start to get into redistribution of resources,
managing and regulate in the power of the most powerful people.
And whenever that conversation starts,
it gets shut down because we want to conserve.
Even in a capitalist system.
Wouldn't it be more ethical if everybody started from the same starting block?
Well that's what's wrong with the world,
right?
What's wrong with the world as some people are in a,
they have a terrible hand of cards.
You've been dealt,
you know,
and my point about food is that the people that are going to sue,
they're going to suffer the most,
are the people that rely on the cheap food.
Cheap food gets pulled away.
Then a lot of those supermarkets in a lot of those,
um,
fast food stores that rely on that factory farm food,
you know,
they're going to be in a bad situation.
Things are going to be much more expensive.
And if things are much more,
if they,
if they make animals live,
like,
um,
what does that guy's name?
Polyface farms.
Joel's Salitan.
Yeah,
he's a fascinating cat.
I had him on my podcast before he sort of a farm reformist.
And what he believes is that these animals should live just like animals.
When he has pigs,
he puts them in a fenced area,
but he moves the fence Daria every day.
So like the pigs move to a different spot.
And so they're just constantly forging and eating acorns and uh,
but they're,
you know,
they're living like a pig.
They're living in a natural,
they're not living in some crazy warehouse.
Yes,
it does.
Same with his chickens.
He has this mobile chicken coop and he moves it from pasture to pasture.
And this is how he operates his entire farm?
Yes.
It seems again the appointment it's been,
we've talked about earlier that we ought to like if we look at that,
no one knows what's right.
So perhaps what we could try and do is replicate what we do naturally and so
there is an argument that naturally we do hunt.
There is a an argument that naturally we do eat meat.
There is an actually Grobe food too though.
Right?
Judgmental.
I thought it was saying like getting into organic gardening.
If you have your own garden man,
I mean that is like one of the most Karma free things ever.
If you could figure out a way to have your own compost,
your own garden and you don't ever have to rely on anybody else for your food,
well then you're not participated
shit at all.
Do you think that the spirit of entrepreneurship could be turned to designing
these systems?
Do you think the only thing that incentivizes people is maximum profit?
I do too.
I think the ease possible that people would sit around and go like,
how do we organize a society that is fair and just that doesn't kill people's
individualism or creativity or right to pursue different goals are to be who
they are.
Believe who you know.
But like I feel like there's so much fog in the air.
People don't know what they actually believe in because it's so much powerful
cultural influence,
so much toxin,
physical toxin,
literal toxins and toxicity,
cultural toxicity.
You know,
how are,
how am I to,
uh,
protect my children from cultural influences that telling them,
do you have to look this way,
be this way,
behave that way.
These are the things that call if you're not this,
you're not a man.
If you're not this,
you're not a woman.
You know,
like,
Whoa,
you know,
as a parent,
I feel the obligation to create an environment where they can grow up to be who
they are in inverted commas.
And then when you sort of scowled it up to a society,
you know,
how can we start to recognize,
look is this time to look at different systems for living.
And I,
what I feel is people want to be involved in that,
in the power systems that affect them.
Like if you have a group of a hundred people,
they want a bit bout of run their own schools,
run their own care systems,
run it'd be in charge of their own life,
not just be some little beam of energy flicked about by cultural forces that
they can't reach or touch.
It's alienating and like one of the things he marks,
he's him and that you know,
and I know very little about this subject does,
he says that when capitalism reaches a certain point,
people will be glossed,
alienated.
They'll feel like a cog in a machine.
No one will have no pride in their work.
No one will know what it's like to make a whole bicycle and think,
look,
I made that.
You'll just,
you're the guy that makes the pedals now fuck off home now.
Like,
you know,
like I've listened to enough Jordan Peterson to understand that there are
limitations to what socialism and Marxism can achieve.
But just because you know,
capitalism is better than feudalism,
that doesn't mean that's the end of the conversation that we shouldn't be
looking for are more just ways of living.
Um,
yeah.
I don't know of capitalism as the problems or maybe it's how people engage with
capitalism.
Maybe it's what people choose to focus on.
If you're just about acquiring wealth and money,
some people are,
yeah,
they're going to be very deeply unhappy and it's going to be this weird game of
acquiring influence and power to,
you just have this insurmountable mound of money that you live on top of.
Right.
I don't think that's a good way for them either.
I think if we're gonna really,
we're going to look at this country fairly,
we have to look at think of all the poor neighborhoods and manage and being born
in those poor neighborhoods and imagine being born to place where there's no
resources.
There's no how you live in the fucking mountains of West Virginia.
Those coal mining communities or people or it's all just mobile homes and pills
and it's chaos,
but it just extreme poverty.
What do you do if you're stuck in there?
What have you,
if you're born to that clan,
that's the group you're born into,
you're fucked man.
You're fucked.
We have to take our resources and concentrate on parts of America the same way.
We concentrate on many other problems,
spots in the world and look at them as like,
hey man,
there's this spot where people are fucked.
We should unfucked them.
We should figure out a way to go into every single horrible
community in this country,
on this planet,
ones that are just as bad as some of that you see in third world countries.
They exist right here in America fixed that.
It's only ignore that.
That's crazy though.
If they're in Detroit,
if they're in wherever the fuck they are,
whatever,
whatever the horrible community is.
Why isn't there a concerted national effort to eliminate that?
That's a major source of crime.
It's a major source of pride.
People feel like they got fucked over in life,
so they want to get at you and take from you because you got that easy road.
Hey man,
you're born the fucking suburbs.
Hey Man,
your mom and dad are still together.
You know?
Hey Man,
your,
your dad has a job and your mom's at home baking and show you live like a
motherfucker,
Norman Rockwell movie.
Fuck you man.
My Mom's on crack.
My mom's a prostitute.
My life is hell.
My Dad beats me.
I've been sexually molested since I was a little kid.
This is the reality that people exist and they don't feel like anybody's coming
to help them.
We,
we need to concentrate on that.
If the government,
if the government really cares about us,
if they're really involved in social engineering and making America better
again,
make those places better.
Those are the places you need to concentrate on.
Not Tax breaks for fucking super rich corporations that get you in place.
Then they make enough money.
Man,
that's not the problem.
The money where the money goes,
what's it being allocated towards?
The biggest problem in our country is he's in impossible to escape communities.
It's so many people just get sucked into this trap and for every person that
gets out and becomes a basketball player or a successful businessperson and they
have this story about the poverty that they grew up and they,
they are so rare and it's not to be applauded that they got through that.
It is,
but it's more to be,
we should understand like,
hey,
we've got a real fucking problem that we're churning out all these people that
live with,
they start out in life with a massive deficits,
start out in life,
emotionally fucked,
physically abused.
They start out with everybody around them is a loser.
Everybody's going to jail.
Everybody is constantly doing pills or this or that.
The it's all negative.
And to ask them to develop their own positive mindset uniquely in a vacuum,
it's preposterous.
It's all these pull them up by your bootstraps.
All those assholes,
hey,
you got to pull yourself up by your bootstraps.
Like they don't even have boots,
man.
You don't understand.
Like you don't know what you're talking about.
You,
you've never seen it,
you've never been involved in that kind of poverty.
It's not fair.
It's not fair at all.
If we care about people that's we should fucking care about.
Yes,
I couldn't agree more.
That's the number one problem.
And it's everywhere in the world.
All the,
all the crime and poverty.
Well,
imagine if everyone the lowest you could live,
it's like a middle class existence.
Yes.
Boy,
everybody would all be a lot more fucking relaxed if you always had meals,
you always had food.
You always had a roof over your head.
Everyone lives Middleclass Holy Shit.
I mean obviously that's way past the expectations that we have right now for the
world because like $34,000 a year globally puts you in the world 1% you know?
I mean that's the w if you make $34,000 a year,
which is to live on,
man,
did you?
You're in the 1% of the world.
But that stand it that you've very eloquently described is I think achievable
and that won't be the aim.
And when you give just one example of how legislate the bias of legislation is
continually to support the powerful while making the just making nominal
gestures to poverty.
Yeah.
I'm a little gestures like where you put that.
Yeah and that's the the the,
if there is a point in nation,
if there is a point to a flag in our belief and this idea that there is an
America and there is a Britain and we're all together and we're all one and
we've got a common destiny in a common past,
then if we're not,
if we're ignoring and neglecting those communities then I say that is what
defines us.
You know,
and until there are systems codes,
regulations that prioritize that we will continue to live in something heading
to what if not a dystopia.
I think moving in the direction of dystopia where the priorities and a dreams
are sort of owned really by the kind of a bit mad evil insect robot images that
we've seen discussed that people do get very concerned when someone reaches a
point of excessive power and influence like a Jeff Bezos type character.
When you see some guy who not,
he doesn't have $1 million,
like wow,
guys got $1 million.
Like he must be so relaxed so that so much money.
Now he's got 150 billion and he works every day maniacally and he's constantly
doing new projects and new things and buying out whole foods.
And that's like pinnacle capitalism is one of the things that scares people the
most when someone just acquire,
it's just insane position of power and wealth.
Like like a Bill Gates type character who is very altruistic,
very,
very generous.
Bill Gates,
accuser,
one of the better examples of someone who gains a lot of money and then it does
a lot to help people,
especially in his retirement.
All,
all they do is focus on charitable organizations and yeah,
which is brilliant,
marvelous.
And you know,
I'm not criticizing the great achievements of brilliant people,
but like it really for me that demonstrates their limb.
The limitations come from the type of system as we live in that you can't
through charity effect every impoverished community in America.
You know,
like we,
the systems that we have are,
are,
well,
if you're poor like that,
you know,
the bootstrap model,
well this guy did it.
Look at this great guy who overcame the odds,
you know,
until like,
I feel like in a sense charity is become a kind of valve that allows that,
you know,
people like you and I who aren't poor to feel like,
well I'd do a bit in,
Oh,
I'm sort of involved.
I can wash my hands of it when you know what these,
unless we,
there is no America,
there is no England.
Unless we have integral relationships with one another,
we support one another.
If we really are on a team,
when we see someone who's completely downtrodden,
who's on our team and we ignore them,
well that's not much of a fucking,
is it?
No.
I mean that's what I feel like when it come to red lights and I see homeless
people,
I feel terrible.
I'm like,
I feel like,
you know,
I mean there's,
part of me is like don't give him any money because they know they're going to
just buy drugs.
You know?
Let them figure it out,
but then they're not going to figure it out.
They have mental health issues and they're supposedly on the team.
They probably were born in America.
They probably have national citizenship here.
You know,
they,
this is our team and no one gives a fuck that they're camped out under the
bridge.
It's like the,
the diffusion of responsibility that comes with these massive numbers,
20 million in La,
300 and plus whatever it is now.
What is it like three 20 in American?
Yeah.
It's unbelievable.
I think there's 90,000 in the General California.
Look at cities worth of homeless people isn't,
it is not difficult for me to envisage.
Like when we talk about the transcendent states that can be achieved through
meditation and Psychedelics,
meaning that beings like us can access them.
It's not difficult to envisage human,
like a type of creature type of being.
A little more evolved in us that we'd look back and say,
oh my God,
they allowed homelessness.
They allowed those impoverished communities or why was it I have this belief in
competitive systems and survival of the fittest that we're resourced from ideas
that weren't really meant to be translated into that.
When you were talking before about by the natural world is fraught with
competition and Fred of course,
is that these animals,
so you know,
I'm not disputing what you're saying there,
but we can't transpose onto an economic system,
survival of the fittest.
If you ain't got enough hustle and muscle,
fuck you.
You have to do a down by the wayside.
You know?
Here we have an obligation to aspire to the better parts of our nature.
Not to continually use materialism and rationalism to justify that 20% of the
population,
you know,
or whatever it was,
energy is adjust garbage or just waste and there,
that's affordable.
We can occur,
we can live with that.
For me it's that,
why would we,
once we have the knowledge that,
oh yeah,
we shouldn't be farming in that way.
Oh,
we shouldn't have social systems.
All of the,
the answer's always the same because if you were to change in that area,
it will affect the interest of the powerful,
it will affect,
impede the ability of certain organizations to make profit.
Now I'm,
yeah,
I'm not talking about,
you know,
I don't know the lexicon enough around socialism and capitalism and Marxism and
various forms of social organization.
I'm just talking about my assumption that we're all resorbed from the same basic
material and phenomenal.
We all have compassion and love in us and if we on an individual level can
achieve some level of access to that,
then we can start to organize ourselves on that basis,
not on the basis of,
well,
what's the most I can get as an individual?
It's rational for me to read.
I'm not involved in that.
That doesn't affect me personally,
you know,
and I think it's a hard thing for us to hold.
I think the reason we all do just live with homelessness and the only decision
we make is do we put a couple of dollars out the window at the light or not?
Then like big,
it's hard to hold that.
It's hard to love more than a hundred feet.
Yeah.
There's no fix.
Like there's no as an individual,
but not one person and even collectively as a group when you have mental health
issues,
unless you want to institutionalize those people.
Yeah,
but then who,
here's the thing,
right?
If everyone has a unique,
and if everyone has their own ideas about what to do with their life and
everyone has freedom,
what if you just don't have enough people that are interested in,
in mental health of the homeless people?
He just don't have enough.
There's no resources.
Guarantee results.
Yeah.
That's a big question because our systems are biased in a particular direction.
If they have government funding,
do you think that that could cure homelessness?
One of the advantages I've got of being a drug addict is it means I have to help
have a traffic ad ex is part of my own recovery.
This puts me into areas,
institutions,
groups,
facilities where our meat and drug addicts and always what you'll find that
people that work there,
there's always someone like a man or a woman.
Most often in my personal experiences as a woman,
some matriarchal woman full of mother energy that just will do this shit forever
for free,
for nothing that just loves it.
There's just put herself like my grandmother did or my mother did or like these
women do between people in the gutter that are just willing to say,
I'll be the person,
I'll be the person in la at friendly house.
It was a woman called Peggy Albrecht but it used to run a play a friend in
houses have for women that have got drug and addiction and abuse issues and like
this woman,
she was from Chicago,
she was nine years old by the time like I'm actually,
I'm so rude and brilliant and beautiful and entirely willing to dedicate herself
and I think every community everywhere,
everyone knows people like that and I feel like the same way as like if it is
someone that has got great capacity or play basketball or be a comic,
like I think that when you spot those people that you encourage them and help
them.
Yeah,
the talent of compassion and love that.
But we don't value that unless it's like,
unless it could be turned to a profit fuck off.
All of those organizations like those,
uh,
organizations that help people with addiction issues,
you know,
they are maligned and like the people that profit from the opioid crisis,
they are supported,
they are able to conceal as John Oliver Brilliantly revealed that they,
they're able to conceal their practices continually.
The invisible biases in the direction of profit and like the failure of certain
types of socialism doesn't mean that's the end of the argument.
I think we have an obligation to look for ways of accessing our own,
uh,
higher nature,
better nature kind of nature.
Call it what you will and seeing how we can organize that.
I as an individual,
you can do so much.
I mean,
if,
if Bill Gates can,
you know,
fucking no,
I had no cure malaria and make the significant charitable Dana,
these impressive,
powerful people can't make a meaningful difference,
then clearly this is a systemic problem.
Well,
there's also the problem with homeless people and that they're adults.
Um,
when you become an adult and you develop from the time you were a child,
it's probably very likely that the damage was all done while they were young.
They were probably abused and neglected,
and there's a lot of issues that led them to either have mental health problems
or they had mental health problems or ready maybe their genetic problems.
Then on top of that,
there's drug abuse to you for each one of those people to get well,
you're going to need a massive amount of folks.
You're not going to have one old lady who's rude.
Brilliant.
That's a cute movie.
Never.
That's 20 people.
Yeah.
It's a good movie.
Quite shut down.
Write
it down.
Who would,
who would be the woman
Faye Dunaway or some shit like the one that was,
uh,
out of golden girls,
Estelle Getty.
She's still available.
Oh,
God.
Wrapped pretty white store around Betty White.
Still hanging in there.
Yeah,
but would you book a movie around her stink.
Hang on.
How are we going to fund this?
Yeah,
it's,
um,
yeah,
you're right.
Look there's limitation to the individual,
but there's not like crushed his optimism in the crib.
Now Joe,
because I know that trashing the optimism,
but I'm saying the logistics of it would almost be insurmountable and it's very
hard to,
it is not an objective thing.
It's this thing that's been biased over time.
Sort of once a person has developed once they're assuming it's very difficult to
turn that train around.
Yeah.
If we can,
you know,
saves the community and Save the future,
like help like less people get through fucked help,
let help more people get through with hope and with a real possibility for
improving their life versus have this sense of hopelessness that many are
confronted with that's going to make less crime.
I agree.
That's just,
if they,
if someone looked at it from a social engineering stand point,
I'd almost seems like they will.
The only way that would ever have to happen would be there's be some fucking
catastrophe that force people to act like we sometimes need something that's
shoved in our face to force us to act,
but if someone brilliantly calculated the amount of resources that it would
require and then also brilliantly calculated how much less crime it would have,
how much less,
how many more innovations because people didn't waste their lives.
In fact,
they got through life and used one of the most valuable resources we have,
which is the human imagination and creativity and ingenuity like,
and we're missing that on these people that are growing up in these horrible
environments where they can't escape.
They're so fuck from,
they're in gangs there,
you know the crime and poverty and violence,
there's so fucked that whatever genius they have is wasted on this nonsensical
existence.
If they could just show that and quantify how much that would be,
how valuable that would be to the overall culture and community of the co of the
continent and then ultimately of the earth.
I mean you would have a reason to engineer think about this.
Beautiful.
That is really beautiful and it's interesting that the way that I agree with you
that it almost has to at some point be translated into monetary value because
otherwise people don't seem to read it.
Yeah,
and safety for everybody,
for them who live in these horrible communities wouldn't be great.
Again,
if everybody lived like a middle class person,
the idea that that's impossible seems so insane.
It's almost seems like,
well then nobody should live like that.
Then like either everybody should be able to live like that or nobody should
build the boy.
That was like,
that's what everybody really wants,
right?
You want to be comfortable like in terms of like your ability to exist and then
all the things you're doing that you struggle with should be a good percentage
of them other than emotional and friendship type thing should be of your own
choosing.
You choose to take a difficult path.
You choose to take an adventure.
You choose to try to enrich yourself with this difficult experience and the
challenge of it and try to overcome that challenge instead of you.
Your challenge is not to get killed by a gang.
You know,
your,
your challenge is not get fucked by your uncle again.
You know what I mean?
I mean,
this is what people have to deal with and you're,
you're missing these brilliant minds.
They don't get this chance to come through and,
and sneak through that fucking salmon ladder.
You know,
get up to that
top.
This would be a very,
uh,
beautiful that you are passionate about this.
And I think popularizing these ideas is important because I feel that then
people will be familiar with this kind of language and we'll recognize that when
there is a political discourse.
How phatic an empty is that people will say,
you know,
like I think in the last election in your country,
it was clear that there was no one,
no one is saying that no one,
no one is standing on a political platform of,
do you know what everyone should basically be,
I live a middle class.
Lifestyle is no reason.
There's enough resources.
We can do this.
We could organize society on that basis because that's considered outlandish and
crazy and we're so,
there's so much I can again,
you know,
with your imaginary listener,
the listener that would consider this pontification,
you know,
there's so much anger I can,
I feel that a lot of political events that have occurred in the last five years
are the manifestation of a social rage of people that are pissed off with not
being heard.
A pissed off with a cultural conversation that didn't include them,
uh,
and that they feel angry and I don't want to help other people.
Fuck knows.
But you know,
that that resource is becoming sort of nurtured and grown.
And I feel people would feel tremendous relief to let go of that.
You have to feel like this and it's all right for you to be you.
Could we be a little more aspirational and a,
a little and consider what our goals are.
Consider what progress looks like to us is progress.
The terrifying robots or his progress considering elevate in the lowest among us
to raise the Stan.
If people could just understand that this,
this is not forever.
You don't,
there is no such thing as forever.
This is a temporary thing.
It,
you've gotta try to Eke as much good out of this as you can and to go against my
point.
You know,
there's a real problem with people being lazy.
People are lazy.
There's not an equality of effort.
The idea of the quality of outcome,
like people want,
you know,
income equality.
Well,
there's no effort.
Equality,
that's just the fact.
There's people out there that are just,
they work harder,
they're smarter,
they're more focused,
they are less distracted.
The more dedicated they have a better plan,
they've thought it through better and they become more successful.
And the idea that they become more successful than you because somehow or
another there's some nefarious actions of foot.
Well that that
negates another possibility,
which is you're lazy cunt.
That's a possibility.
Yes.
And what do we do about those people?
I tell you this,
I've got a plan for the Lazy Lazy Island.
You're all going to laser.
It's a bit like Pinocchio's donkey land.
No Arcade Games though.
They're too lazy.
I feel like I'm,
well I consider this that people that don't have a lot of life force,
like I feel like it's a gift to be a person that's got a lot of drive to be a
person that's like,
I'm fucking going to achieve this shit.
You know,
like there's some people that are the little lethargic and don't have a lot of
energy.
I feel that's a kind of despondency.
We could break that down in a thousand different ways.
Is it poor diet?
Is it poor role models?
Is it poor social conditioning?
Who are these lazy people?
Genius could be weak genes to even weak genes.
Then we'd like in the territory of disability so it however you look at it,
I think you end up at a point of compassion.
I think.
I think we should start at the point of compassion cause other or like what is
tolerance if it isn't the tolerance of people that we sort of can't understand.
As long as they carry their own weight,
we usually don't have a problem with it.
But when they're so lazy,
they just Juke the system and screw people over and figure their way to scam
through life.
But I think those people don't exist only at the bottom of the social ladder.
I think they exist at the top.
And the effect there is worse [inaudible] about the president of United States
because this is my country.
Motherfucker.
You better be actually met your president and I do found him to be delightful.
Yeah,
that's the sort of figures.
So very sort of sweet.
Again,
like I say,
I don't judge them either.
One there,
I interviewed him about five years ago.
I was doing we suppose for,
he was the provost.
The president was okay,
let me near him.
He's present.
I went back over the fence,
all that alone.
The Wall.
I like it.
Like he,
um,
yeah,
he was sort of sweep.
I remember thinking,
well I felt was why you don't have no intellectual curiosity.
That's what I felt.
Well,
that's what I felt.
I felt like I was some sort of liked him.
He was nice and the staff at that big tower,
they all loved him,
but curiosity and I don't think he's been very genuine with that.
Great.
Make America great again for you.
I don't lie.
Where's that?
Everyone should be middle class.
We're going to start reorganizing society,
reaching out into Detroit and in a crush mining towns in West Virginia.
Where's that?
Other than the wise,
you ain't making America great again.
That's true.
But think about how we were talking about Dave Chappelle,
but one of the reasons why he's so great other than the fact that he's smart,
just touting all these good things is that he knows what he does and he does it
right.
That's his wheelhouse.
He stays in there.
Trump's wheelhouse is making giant gold buildings with his name on them and
Spray Tan.
He knows what the fuck to do and he knows how to make money and he doesn't give
a fuck about all that other stuff cause that other stuff is wasted energy for
him.
His energy is in focusing on how you get more buildings with those giant gold
Trump letters on it.
And no one can argue that it's been a tremendous success.
One of those hotels,
the water bottle had his face on it.
You know what I mean?
He's amazing.
Incredible.
What an achievement.
I've been drinking coffee bean side of his face,
but that's his thing,
right?
It's like,
why is it okay for your thing to be tennis?
And that's all you know about.
I don't even pay attention to the politics.
Why is that okay?
But when we see a guy like him,
we have a problem with it because he's not,
his intellectual curiosity is only about money.
So it's even grocer.
I agree.
Listen,
this show were to return to my point.
I wouldn't waste time judging anyone or is it as an individual?
Because I imagine if I were to spend time examining Donald Trump's past his
relationship with his father,
the conditions he grew up in,
what he felt he had to do to be a good person,
I would imagine I'd go,
yeah,
of course.
But what I would query is a system that elevates people like that.
And I,
you know,
the two positions of incredible power and you know,
again,
I believe that it's systems that need to change now individuals and I think
we've overly fetishized politics.
I don't live in this country so I don't know if it's much worse under Trump.
I've heard some things that sound really bad then it was under Barack Obama,
but what my more,
my general belief is,
you indeed don't fetishize individuals and get distracted to think about
changing the system because you're not getting that middle class lifestyle for
everyone.
[inaudible] no one's offering that Bernie Sanders isn't offering that.
No one's offering that.
And unless someone's offering that,
what's the,
where while should we get involved?
Have you ever talked to economists about like what is the problem?
What's the like people that are,
you know,
more socialistic minded,
there'd be more socialist minded I guess,
but understanding of capitalism to the point where they could point out the
flaws in allowing this infinite growth model where someone gets to a point like
a Jeff Bezos or something like that,
what would they do to mitigate that?
You're not going to put a cap.
Like that's when people say that like you're going to pay 70% of taxes over $10
million.
I was like one of the ones that was banded about people just start laughing like
you're out of your fucking mind.
No one's going to do that.
They'll get to $10 million and then they'll stop.
Yeah,
it's stupid.
It's,
that's I think a very linear in system and I feel that the problems are broader
than that.
I think that the,
like did you ever see like,
you know,
if you've ever watched Steve Bannon talk that he's a man,
like you know,
someone that I would again not politically agree with for what it's worth,
but when he's description of what happened in that economic crash of 2008 and
the decisions that were made further,
you know,
American taxpayer,
Tear Bay allow the light financial industry and I've seen subsequently seen a
documentary that said,
look,
this is why we had to do that.
These were the options.
But for me that is a demonstration of capitalism's inherent failings and
limitations that we're not talking about a system that is flawless and perfect.
It's pretty fucking floored.
Aside from the cumin collateral damage and the that you have,
again,
describe the,
the,
the communities that are impoverished and without hope and living in poverty in
a kind of slavery,
you know,
even in itself doesn't work according to its own rules.
It has to be art officially sustained and reboot it when it inevitably fails.
So the pure sign of it is that the fact that no one went to jail for the
subprime mortgage crisis,
those guys didn't go to jail.
All those guys that were the real financial were looking at it from a distance.
Then we're going,
I see where this is going,
like this is going to blow up.
And a lot of people are gonna lose their houses.
Like you guys are assholes.
Like,
yeah.
Then there was a lot of people that they engage in those predatory loans and
they didn't get punished.
Those,
those guys,
the craziest thing is a lot of them got bonuses.
Yes,
that's right.
There you got bonuses.
Even if the bank,
I bailed out and they said the bonuses are part of their contracts and if they
didn't honor their contracts,
they'd have a hard time hiring these people and there'd be chaos.
And they do just made a reason why they had to give them millions of dollars in
bonuses when they failed.
But you get a bonus and you failed,
like your bank failed and you still get a bonus.
Like you knew about those predatory loans.
You knew about those,
you knew about the subprime mortgage bullshit that was going down in your
business and you just let it ride and now you're going to get,
you're going gonna get a bonus.
What's the bonus for?
We can,
yeah.
What would you have to do to be fine if that the,
yeah,
that's the bonus system.
It'd be jailed.
Yeah.
I mean,
just think about what they're doing to Julian Assange,
right?
They're,
they're,
they're throwing that guy in a jail somewhere that didn't look good,
that embassy move.
No,
but I mean,
the fact that what he did was released information that everybody found very
interesting.
And what they did is crashed the whole fucking economy.
Right.
He's the,
that he was able to write that embassy idea for as long as he,
cause he's not actually in another country.
Is it in London?
I went and visited him in there.
It's a matter of fact.
Just briefly popped in.
So what do you think's going to happen with them?
Well I think he's going to end up serving a pretty lumpy prison sentence
somewhere.
Isn't he?
Thinks they're going to get them on though.
Like what are they going to charge them on?
They're charging them on like hacking charges or some shit now,
which they didn't charge him on before.
Right?
Is that what's emerged and he's going to be extra data to this country.
Is that true?
I don't know.
Well I mean again I suppose this is what happens if you challenge the interest.
If the powerful,
if Trump was really,
your Trump really wanted to get people on his side.
He pardon him.
Do you think about that would be popular cause like someone like that,
Edward Snowden.
Is it like sort of,
obviously I think don't put the lives of people at risk that Erin compromised
military positions.
That seemed like a fairly obvious thing,
but like I don't think they did that,
but no,
it doesn't.
What I understood was they got hacked and someone else released the,
the documents without the names redacted.
Yeah.
It seems to me Wiki leaks never did that.
[inaudible] Snowden,
it's,
it seems to qualify for a hero in pretty much any way you look at it.
And as a 26 year old person making that decision and you had very brilliant,
and I've heard him,
uh,
I think he was on Neil degrasse Tyson's podcast.
They talked to him.
Oh Wow.
Skyper however they did it.
But
did you see in citizen for,
there's a bit like in that film about able to snow and sit us in for,
there's a bit where he's just come out and he's talking to the journalists or
filmmakers that are making the film and scan it.
They can find what do you with this phone,
you can't leave that like everything's like in a sort of a state of mad
enlightenment where he's just seeing the truth.
If they're listening to us now,
you can't fucking have that on.
You've got to let them.
I like this terrifying to watch I'm on because you know,
obviously now he's calmed down.
He's dealt with.
He understands that,
you know,
but it was like a person that was emerging from having seen the other side.
The Matrix.
Yeah.
Many mean he was deep into it and then when he revealed all the information,
they had a fucking,
they were had a man hunt for him,
the guy to hide out in Russia.
He had to seek asylum and our enemy.
Yes.
The whole thing is so strange.
Who Do our power structures actually support?
If someone tells the truth that of population,
they have to flee to Russia.
If someone talks about improper agricultural practices,
that's against the law.
They can be in prison there.
It starts to reveal that the state itself,
the very thing that we revere,
the very thing that we identify is the tool of our oppression.
They want to discourage people from leaking information that makes them look
horrible.
It's that simple.
If you look at what information he leaked and what would it did well it,
you know,
what he did was he revealed things that everyone wanted to know about that we
felt were crying.
It makes me feel that it's as simple as if you knew what we do in order to keep
shit running,
you would revolt.
So we are never going to let you know.
Well,
that for me in a sense is a path that stuffing,
we'll hold on fucking hell.
Oh,
I thought you are elected officials.
You're one of us.
But no,
you're above us.
To the point where someone leaks information about your crimes.
They get locked in this embassy for seven years.
Like what is their crime exactly in comparison to the crimes that he's revealed.
Yes.
That's where it's crazy that when you look at the,
the balance,
the imbalance between what his crime is and the crimes that he's revealed,
I mean,
he's revealed some staggering crimes and no one's concentrating on that.
The government is not freaking out.
We've got to,
we've left obviously,
uh,
we have work to do,
we have corrections to make.
There's none of that talk.
There's get that guy talk.
That's right.
And like,
it's sort of under the veil of patriotism.
A lot can be concealed.
And that is a,
uh,
an incident that capacities through several administrations.
So like for seven years,
yes.
It makes you think,
well,
what is there the what all the difference is,
you know,
like I kind of,
sort of been on Bill Maher show,
I like Bill Maher,
I'm up,
I'm,
you know,
very simple,
fake tear left.
What we need ultimately beyond left,
left wing.
I'm,
you know,
trying to,
my belief is that we should try and organize a system based on hallucinogenic
experience for fuck sake.
There's,
there's no party for me and I'm not even allowed to fucking hallucinogens.
So like,
you know,
so like I'm like,
I'm not a right wing person.
It's safe to say,
but like I feel that so many of the problems that we're experiencing now is
because the democratic left wing liberal organizations stopped serving the
people.
They were in the case of the British Labor Party designed,
set up to surf.
They neglected them,
they abandoned them.
You know,
the white with the white working class in Britain were 50 60 years ago,
told,
hey,
there's this thing called Britain.
We want you to go out there and fight and die for it.
Give up your sons.
Get out there.
Oh,
and now they're told,
hey,
there's no such thing as a Britain.
And like,
yeah,
no wonder people are confused.
No one there.
People are baffled.
No wonder there are abandoned constituencies and despair and rage.
And I,
I feel that in a way it's like,
what is patriotism resourced from a sense that we all need to belong,
but we want to be together that,
you know,
look,
we're willing to believe in a fictional idea,
a flag,
and a story about,
you know,
the origin of a nation.
Whether that's an old one like mine or a new one like this one.
You know,
we're willing to participate in that,
but if those values aren't real,
if they aren't like,
if it is,
we are going to support the most powerful.
We will lie to you whenever necessary.
When our lives are revealed will imprison,
punish,
and lie about those people.
We don't care about the most vulnerable.
What the fuck is the flag that we are waiving?
Who is it for?
It's good point.
And on that note,
what's wrap this bitch up?
Good.
We went out high.
We went there was a good one.
It was a good way to end it.
Russell,
you're awesome man.
I love show all every day.
You always like being around you and your book mentors.
It's out.
Now your podcasts would be available on luminary starting 23rd 23rd of this
month.
So just a few days ladies.
Gentlemen,
that's the end of the show.
Okay.